Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Man müsste vielleicht meine Internetpartei gründen, findest du dich auch?
Mega Idee.
Mega, super Ideen, alles was man braucht für die Planung der Zukunft, gibt's heute bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Hatten wir den mega Song eigentlich schon mal am Ende oder hatten wir uns damals dagegen entschieden, weil äh kennst du den Mega.
Ja ja ja ich weiß grad nicht mehr, ich glaube doch, ich glaube das hat äh.
Ich glaube, das können wir denen wir hatten uns da, glaube ich, dagegen entschieden, weil wir ähm weil wir uns nicht klar waren, wie viele Hörerinnen wir dadurch verlieren.
Achso, ja, das kann auch sein.
Ja.
War irgendwas? Wir mussten wieder eine Woche ausfallen lassen. Das ist äh gerade ein wenig ein äh Dilemma. Ähm das sich leider nicht verhindern ließ, aber äh na ja.
Ich war diesmal wirklich richtig in einer richtig schönen Stadt.
Wirklich, ist doch mal schön.
Meiner absoluten Lieblingsstadt, muss ich wirklich sagen, New York. Ich bin jedes Mal völlig außer mir, bin völlig beeindruckt, unglaublich. Gute, gute Leute da getroffen und äh Schönwetter gehabt, kann ich, also,
was will man mehr? Weißt du was man mehr will?
Na super, ne, dann dann bist du ja jetzt auf jeden Fall richtig durchgecheckt.
Ich muss ja mal angeben, weißt du was man mehr will? Abends zum Sonnenuntergang auf dem Hudson River Segeln.
Gemacht. Wow. Zur Freiheitsstatue.
Wow, ne. Glück gehabt, dass sie nicht gerade im Flugzeug gelandet ist. Na ja, das gab's schon mal.
Hudson River. Ja, nee, aber war war wirklich toll. Also, vielen Dank, danke, danke, dass dich das so interessiert, wie schön meine letzte Woche ohne dich war. Ja.
Ja, das stellt mir das ganz toll vor.
Kommen wir vielleicht äh zu den Inhalten.
Ja, genau.
Da hatten wir ja äh auch ein Paar, beziehungsweise Inhalte, hatten auch ein paar deutsche Provider unerwarteter Maßen beziehungsweise eine Inhaltsentnahme und ähm tja
Telekom, und,
mir bis dahin noch nicht wirklich bekannter Provider Stella, der wohl auf Satellitenkommunikation spezialisiert ist.
Die stehen laut einem Spiegelbericht jetzt äh da,
am Pranger, kann man vielleicht nicht sagen, aber im Verdacht äh von der NSA geohnt worden zu sein.
Ja, das äh das Projekt, um das es da geht, nennt sich ja irgendwie Trashermap, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Der NSA-Term für äh wir kartografieren äh das gesamte Internet und wollen wissen, wo die Schätze sind, ja. Und im Rahmen dieser ähm.
Internetschätzchen.
Ja und also wie man ja schon sagt, wenn es existiert, dann hört die NSA es ab ähm und da haben sie natürlich sich auch um äh solche Anbieter dann ähm gekümmert.
Und was ich eigentlich ganz spannend fand oder was sich vor dem Hintergrund interessant finde ich man natürlich,
Also da da hat jetzt keiner mehr einen Zweifel dran, dass diese Geschichte Credible ist, ja? Ähm Spiegel Online veröffentlichte dann ein Video, wo der.
Was eigentlich von The Intersep war das Video, also mehr oder weniger im Auftrag. Da stand auch Fett vorne drauf.
Weil der Typ war ja doch, das war doch der Rosenbach. Ja? Okay, also dann die arbeiten ja, die stecken alle unter einer Decke.
Ja ja genau, also die Laura Portraits, irgendwie haben die das produziert und unter anderem dann eben auch dem Spiegel zur also.
Genau, also hat's gefilmt und der, der Mann, der da die äh der da mit hinspricht, gefilmt wurde, ist ja, glaube ich, in äh Hürth bei Köln. Und ähm der Mann, der da die, die Belege eben vorliegt, das ist der,
Rosenbach vorm Spiegel, der ja da hauptsächlich dieses ganze Thema beackert oder einer der vielen,
Spiegel und Spiegel Online-Leute ist dieses Thema irgendwie bar kann. So und in diesem Video setzen die sich, also ich weiß nicht genau, welche Art von Journalismus das jetzt irgendwie sein sollte, dieses Video. Ähm.
Mir war irgendwie nicht ganz also keiner, was sollte das? Ja, also äh der Typ sitzt da, zeigt diesen Mitarbeitern, die offensichtlich nicht,
Wissen, was auf sie zukommt oder was ihnen da gezeigt wird oder nur grob wussten, was ihnen da gezeigt hat. Sagt er dann, zeigt er dann irgendwie so, ja guck mal hier, ne, das das weiß die NSA alles. Ähm,
Und hier sind eure die Namen eurer Mitarbeiter, die irgendwie spezifisch überwacht werden und dann sitzt der Typ da und sagt, ja scheiße, das ist unser,
Zentrum unseres gesamten der Hauptarchitekt unseres gesamten äh Netzes so ungefähr. Das ist schon ziemlich übel, wenn der überwacht wird, weil der Zugang auf alles. Ähm.
Und was also was soll das?
Weiß ich nicht, hat so ein bisschen was von so einer Samstagnachmittag äh Talk Sendung so mit. Und hier.
Genau. Hier ist ihr neues Wohnzimmer.
Und hier ist ihre Freundin, die sie seit zwei Wochen lang betrogen hat. Wir waren mit der Kamera dabei.
Und hier wollen sie mal ein Ultraschallbild von ihrem neuen Kind sehen, was sie von ihrem Nachbarn erwartet.
Was sagen Sie zu diesem Vaterschaftstest? Also irgendwie so.
Ja, echt super. Wir haben da mal ein paar DNA-Proben genommen.
Ja, also das war irgendwie keine Ahnung, welche, was das jetzt sollte, aber äh das Video hatte einen sehr interessanten, kleinen Teil, den ich dann sehr, der mir so, der mir dann so als,
So als ich gucke ja hin bei so einem Video, dann auffiel,
niemand anders irgendwie bis jetzt drüber berichtet, weil zwar zeigten sie dann offensichtlich so ein äh Host beziehungsweise Device von einem, derer Core Router, ja? Und das Gerät hatte offensichtlich so die die interne Bezeichnung Horizon,
und da drunter stand.
Das Passwort.
Was offenkundig das Passwort war.
Also da stand nicht Passwort dran, aber es machte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als sei das jetzt gemeint.
Also wenn du in so einem wenn du jetzt in so einem internen NSA-Wicki irgendwie dokumentierst, wie du Zugriff auf dieses Gerät kriegst, dann schreibst du natürlich was weiß ich User, Passwort oder äh oder Ho.
User nehmen, gab's ja da nichts. Es gab ja da nur ein Passwort.
Wie gesagt, da standen nur zwei Worte. Ja und das eine, das erste Wort war Horizon und das zweite Wort war Horizon in Leadsbeeak. Ja, also H null, R eins, Z null N, ja?
Und ähm mir ist jetzt also es ging jetzt nicht ganz daraus hervor, ob das jetzt rausnehmen, Passwort fahren oder User nehmen und Passwort, aber,
egal ob's jetzt der Hostname oder der war, ja das Passwort gleichlautend in Leadspeak, das macht jeder Passwort Cracker
automatisch als allererstes, selbst wenn du ihm das nicht sagst, dass er es tun soll, ja, nimmt er halt das gleiche Wort nochmal, also es ist ähm,
Da kann man schon wirklich von von sträflicher ähm,
Nachlässigkeit sprechen und ähm meinen meine Erfahrung ist, dass das jetzt überhaupt keine äh Einzel oder Sonderfall ist, ja, dass ähm kritische äh Netzelemente derart äh konfiguriert sind.
Man muss dazu sagen, üblicherweise ist der schwierige Teil auch überhaupt in das äh Operations made in ins Network zu kommen. Das heißt,
Normalerweise gegenüber der dem freien Internet oder den Nutzern sollten diese Geräte ihre Admin äh admin,
Zugänge ihrer Protokolle, was wir, ob's jetzt SSH sei oder eine Web Goi oder sonst was, wie die Geräte äh konfiguriert werden, gar nicht
freilegen, also der der kritischere Teil des Hacks, äh den die NSA da offensichtlich durchgeführt hat, wird nochmal an einer anderen Stelle liegen, nämlich dass die überhaupt in dieses Operations und ins Network gekommen sind.
Aber ähm,
da dann eben derartige Passwörter zu haben ähm ist eben etwas, was noch nie in Ordnung war und auch in Zukunft jetzt nicht mehr sein wird.
Also Stella hat ja jetzt irgendwie da nochmal eine ein Statement dazu gegeben und meinten, ja, das wäre ja nun alles irgendwie, äh da wäre ja so ein Kundenzugang gehackt
worden und er hätte ja ein unsicheres Passwort verwendet, also irgendwie haben die das jetzt so dargestellt, als sei das ja nur ein Kundenzugang und nicht jetzt irgendwie ein Admin
Zugang eines äh Rautas. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob sich das jetzt exakt
genau auf das äh bezieht, was da jetzt gezeigt wurde oder wie das alles zusammenhängt. Das ist auf jeden Fall etwas unklar. Auf jeden Fall wedeln da alle ganz äh ordentlich mit den Armen und meinen, sie hätten ja nun jetzt wochenlang da äh intensive forensische Analyse und Recherche betrieben. Und äh keiner, also weder Telekom, Nitcolone, noch Stella,
Könnte jetzt irgendetwas finden, wo da äh irgendetwas in Überwachung ist, zumindest,
einer von ihnen registrierbaren Überwachung.
Hm. Ja, das äh das ähm da kommen wir wieder zurück zu so einem zu einem Verdacht, den ich ja schon,
Ganz zu Anfang dieser ganzen Snowden-Sachen geäußert habe, wenn da ernsthaft äh,
wirklich Traffic abgesogen würde, dann sind das natürlich auch massive Volumen, die da irgendwo trans äh veriert werden müssten. Und ähm das halte ich für,
schwierig,
ohne dass es irgendjemanden auffallen würde, ja? Und ähm das lässt den Schluss zu, dass sie entweder nicht alles da wecken, was ich,
grundsätzlich schon auch äh glaube, dass sie es nicht tun
Ja, dass sie jetzt nicht irgendwie alles, was Stella macht, gleichzeitig nochmal ein MirrorPort nach draußen läuft, wo dann irgendwie weiß ich nicht, wie viel Gigabit, obwohl nächstes Jahr Satellit, das passt ja irgendwie durch einen sechsundfünfzig KM oder in Verbindung. Also, aber ähm,
dass sie alles nach draußen führen, halte ich für unwahrscheinlich.
Aber wenn sie's tun, dann können sie's nur tun, indem sie irgendwie die Kapazitäten nutzen, die schon da sind für deutsche Geheimdienste.
Und dann quasi auch in deren Mitwissen. Was ich aber eher glaube, was sie mit diesen Satellitendingern machen, ist die ähm,
Router bei Bedarf manipulieren. Also vielleicht einzelne Verbindungen umleiten nach ihrem Ermessen. Um dadurch irgendwie Myware-Infektionen oder sonstwas zu machen,
Ähm so dass sie quasi, also das Routing,
der Teilnehmer unter Umständen selektiv oder vollständig äh um manipulieren.
Sozusagen.
Nee, weil also noch dazu kommt, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es bei Stella ist und mein Stand, was Satelliten
Internet angeht, ist eher so wirklich viele Jahre zurück, aber damals TM war es so, dass diese Satellitenverbindung
ohnehin bei dem Anbieter, den
ich damals mir mal angeschaut habe ohnehin unverschlüsselt war. Das heißt, dieser ganze dieser Satellit, der strahlt das ja auf die halbe Erdkugel.
Da kann man eh gut zuhören, ja.
Unverschlüsselt drauf. So, da, das heißt, da musst du jetzt nicht mehr die, die Bodenstation des Satellitenanbieters hacken. Aber ich würde jetzt mal ähm,
in den letzten Jahren nochmal angeschaut habe, ähm davon ausgehen, dass sich da in den letzten Jahren etwas getan hat und eventuell die einzelnen Teilnehmerleitungen doch wahrscheinlich hoffentlich ähm.
Oder die einzelnen Teilnehmer äh Streams äh unterschiedlich äh verschlüsselt sind. Das würde ich jetzt äh hoffen.
Muss man sich eh mal klar machen, ne, dass so bei Satelliten äh Providern, die halt nicht ihren Traffic nochmal verschlüsseln. Also die quasi die Datenpakete so, wie sie letzten Endes aufs Internet gelegt werden,
Einfach so ausstreuen, quasi mit so geostationären Satelliten aus sechsunddreißigtausend Kilometer Entfernung über
gesamt Europa strahlen.
Ja, die haben, glaube ich, noch mal so ein bisschen direktionale Antennen, also nicht gesamt Europa, aber jetzt wirklich nicht gezielt zu dir.
Ja okay, also
kann sich auf jeden Fall dezent irgendwo mit dem Wohnmobil hinstellen oder auch noch ein Häuschen dahin bauen. Und irgendwie äh in Ruhe das einfach alles einsammeln. Also ist diese ganze Fragestellung mit wie, ja, wie sind die denn überhaupt an die Kabel rangekommen und so weiter? Das ist da halt
nicht, ne? Das heißt, eigentlich müsste gerade so ein Satelliten-Provider eine,
super enorm starke Grundverschlüsselung über den gesamten Datenstrom per DVD drüber machen.
Vor allem für jeden Nutzer einzeln.
Was bei Satelliten,
okay gut ja für die jeweiligen Empfänge. Ja genau, also für wen's auch also im Idealfall, ja, also so enorm wäre schon mal ein Schritt, wenn sozusagen das überhaupt schon mal ein Key gäbe für die gesamte Kommunikation.
Nochmal kurz, weil jetzt um Stella da jetzt nicht irgendwie äh was falsches zu unterstellen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie's machen oder nicht. Also.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nur allgemein sagen, dass das äh schon ein problematischer Bereich ist, der auf jeden Fall am Anfang nicht bedacht worden ist bei einigen oder vielleicht vielen, gegebenenfalls sogar auch allen. Ja.
Das war auf jeden Fall so der Fall. Das war ganz amüsant eigentlich. Na ja, ähm.
Man merkt ja schon, dass sich da jetzt auch was tut, ne? Also auch grad in der Community
wenn man sich anschaut, nicht nur diese Aktivität nach äh open SSL, sondern das auch in den Standardsbodies jetzt
eine Menge auf den Tisch kommt, wo man irgendwie festgestellt hat, na ja, da gab's schon immer mal so eine Schwäche, jetzt machen wir doch auch mal was, wo das vorher immer so, na ja, passt schon.
Schönes äh auch weil das wird vielleicht zu technisch, aber TCP Cript äh opportunistische Verschlüsselung, vollständiger TCP Verbindung, ist da auch irgendwie so ein Projekt, was bis jetzt noch gar nicht so viel ähm Beachtung gefunden hat.
Gibt's auf jeden Fall viel, aber wir machen ja ein Politik-Podcast und kein Checkpodcast. Ähm das auf jeden Fall jetzt ähm,
wie gesagt, meine meine Theorie, die wollen eher einen Beibedarf für gezielte Angriffe, ähm Routen oder Traffic manipulieren als da tatsächlich abhören. Und wenn sie abhören, dann ist es nicht denkbar, dass sie,
oder kann ich mir schwer einen Weg vorstellen, wie sie da Massenüberwachung betreiben ohne das Wissen oder die Unterstützung
durch äh die äh lokal zuständigen Geheimdienste, denn die haben natürlich sowieso immer ihre LI-Schnittstellen und die sind natürlich in der Lage, ähm,
Auch da äh entsprechende Überwachungen zu machen.
Heißt.
So, aber die NSA darf das ja sowieso alles.
Ja. Und darf sie auch weiterhin.
Dass sie weiterhin äh der Fisk, wie heißt der denn nochmal, Foren Intelligence Valence Court oder so oder ja Fisk ähm schon öfter hier besprochen worden mit den ähm.
Dieses Geheimgericht, was halt irgendwie so Entscheidungen macht, aber man darf halt nicht genau sagen, was eigentlich für welche Entscheidungen und auf welcher Basis auch nicht und äh ja.
Und man darf halt, also die Betroffenen äh Entitäten werden auch über die Entscheidungen nicht informiert.
Also der Inbegriff demokratischer Kontrolle.
Genau. Die haben jetzt grade wieder erlaubt für weitere neunzig Tage alle Telefon-Meterdaten zu sammeln, ne, also hier der der Richtervorbehalt sehr schön, kommt er da zum Tragen.
Also nicht für neunzig Tage lang die zu sammeln, sondern die Metadaten für neunzig Tage nach einer Verbindung.
Nein, nein, die die haben jetzt die Meter da, das Meterdaten sammeln in der momentanen Gesetzeslage, ähm bedarf diese Metadatensammlung eines Berichterbeschlusses,
und dieser dieses Gericht äh,
der genaue gesetzliche Hintergrund ist mir jetzt nicht äh im Klaren, weil der gerade auch im Senat da eben Änderungen äh diskutiert werden,
ja? Aber im Moment ist es so, dass es dem Richter Vorbehalt unterliegt und es offensichtlich so eine Maximaldauer von neunzig Tagen gibt. Und deswegen muss dieser Fisk alle neunzig Tage,
neu den dem Antrag der Geheimdienste über den den Antrag der Geheimdienste entscheiden.
Ob die bisher gesammelten.
Telefonmetadaten der USA sammeln dürfen oder nicht. Und das haben sie jetzt wieder für weitere neunzig Tage erlaubt und am fünften Dezember läuft das aus und da müssen sie's wieder machen.
Also bestelle ich das richtig? Also ob sie das überhaupt tun dürfen oder ob sie die Daten, die sie bisher gesammelt haben, dann löschen müssen. Worum geht's?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es um das Sammeln geht, weil ich ähm.
Aber das, was sie einmal gesammelt haben, ja eben wird dann eh nicht gelöscht. Gut, na dann ist auch, äh dann ist doch gut, wenn man sich ja wieder alle schlafen legen für einen anderthalb Monat.
Ja genau, also für drei Monate ist äh für ja drei, das ist noch drei Monate. Ja, drei Monate.
Man hat überhaupt nicht so den Eindruck, dass jetzt so im Inneren der äh US-amerikanischen Regierungen, die äh sich jetzt mit Geheimdiensten beschäftigt. Und das ist ja ein sehr großer Teil,
irgendein nennenswerter Trend zu verspüren ist grundsätzlich etwas zu ändern. Man eiert sich da so ein bisschen herum.
Da ist tatsächlich äh Trend zu verspüren, dass sich etwas ändert, denn hier geht's ja um Telefonmeterdatenüberwachung innerhalb der USA
und Amerikanes Don't Spy on Americans, ja? Und da gibt's natürlich da, da haste äh wenn's um Spionage innerhalb der USA geht, hast du einen relativ breiten Konsens
von den Konservativen bis zu den ähm Linken.
Dass das ja wohl nicht klargehen kann. Die haben da ein sehr klare Definition
wer jetzt die Guten sind, die äh grundsätzlich, die Amerikaner, als so. Als solche haben sie eine relativ klare Vorstellung davon, wer die Guten in der Welt sind, wer die schlechten oder und sind deshalb sehr, sehr ähm,
empfindlich wenn wenn die US Geheimdienste tatsächlich US-Bürger ähm,
überwachen. Das hat mich schon immer gestört bei den äh Einlassungen von Thomas, dem NSA-Visi.
Kongress, ja.
Ähm der war bei der Ohm, der war,
Beim neunundzwanzig C3 und der hat dann da lange darüber äh referiert, dass er ja ein äh ein anerkannter äh
anerkanntes Mitglied
der der US-amerikanischen Gesellschaft wäre und dass er wohl eine riesige Schweinerei wäre, dass Amerikaner, Amerikanern hinterherspionieren. Und die haben nicht so ein großes Problem damit, dass Amerikaner dem Rest der Welt hinterherspionieren, ja. Ähm,
Was ja auch nachvollziehbar ist, ja. Ich meine, wenn du selber betroffen bist, ist das natürlich was anderes, als.
Also nach dem Ninety Eleven liefen ja so ein paar Leute auf Demos rum mit Schildern. Heute sind wir alle Amerikaner. Also von daher wäre das ja vielleicht auch eine Methode der Sache dann auch nochmal zu entgehen.
Ja, ähm noch ein schöner, noch ein schöner, noch eine schöne Info zu dieser zu diesem Fisk. Und zwar hat die US-Regierung Jaho zweitausendachtzehn,
mit einer äh Geldstrafe von zweihundertfünfzigtausend US-Dollar pro Tag gedroht. Falls Yahu die äh sich nicht nicht,
Nutzerdaten äh massenhaft an die Geheimdienst äh Behörden weitergeben würde.
Hier reden wir dann wahrscheinlich vor allem von Prison, ne, von dem Prison äh Projekt, was ja
Das Erste war, was überhaupt im Rahmen dieser ganzen Snowden Sachen aufgedeckt wurde. Wir erinnern uns
Ja, also zweihundertfünfzig K pro Tag irgendwie, also, weiß nicht, Google kriegt das vielleicht noch gestemmt, aber ich glaube, zweitausendacht saß bei Yahoo grad nicht so gut aus mit der Einnahmenlage, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein ähm dickes Schwert, was sie da ausgepackt haben.
Und das hat ja dann auch am Ende offensichtlich ähm funktioniert. Nur hat halt Yahoo dagegen äh geklagt und bis jetzt wohl geschafft,
eben die Unterlagen exakt dieser Verurteilung oder dieser dieser Androhung ähm zu erhalten. Da war irgendwie von ein paar,
hundert Seiten, Dokumenten die Rede, die,
die sie jetzt so Schritt für Schritt äh veröffentlichen wollen, so so Green World Style. Na, wir haben da jetzt auch mal ein paar Dokumente und jetzt,
jeden Tag eine Seite auf dem Scanner. Bin mal gespannt,
sicherlich jetzt nicht sonderlich überraschend, aber ist mal mal schön zu hören, dass was so die konkrete Drohsumme eigentlich an der Stelle ist und eine Viertelmillion pro Tag. Ja.
Da dauert nicht lange, dann.
Man sich schon, ja, ja, ja.
Und sie haben eben auch sich versucht, dagegen zu wehren, vor diesem äh Fisk. Ähm.
Jetzt ist mir nicht ganz klar, wie Yahoo zweitausendacht von diesem Fisk gewusste und sich tatsächlich dort zur Wehr gesetzt hat, aber offensichtlich hatten die sich ja überhaupt zur Wehr gesetzt, ja, weil ja.
Was meinst du, ob sie wie sie davon wussten, dass es den überhaupt gibt?
Klassischerweise ordnet der Fisk ja Sachen an, äh also Überwachungsmaßnahmen an, wo die Betroffenen eben nicht unbedingt Bescheid wissen.
Und hier war es ja offensichtlich die Regierung, die auf zuging, gesagt hat, ey, äh so und so viel Strafe und dann wird Jaro gesagt haben, ja, wie, wann, wo, baba, baba und dann irgendwann wurde halt wurde
ja hoch offensichtlich der des der des Umstands gewahrt, dass es eben diesen Fisk gäbe, wo sie sich dagegen zur Wehr setzen können. Und da haben sie es eben auch getan,
und da dieses Verfahren haben sie verloren und äh musste dann eben bei Prison mitmachen. Und jetzt am Donnerstag wurden eben wurde.
Die Dokumentation dieses Verfahrens eben freigegeben und liegt unterliegt nicht mehr der Geheimhaltung. Und das geht natürlich auch auf Initiative von,
zurück.
Erinnerst du dich noch, wie das am Anfang war, als die ersten Prison-Meldungen überhaupt in der Welt aufschlugen?
Yahu damals gesagt hat.
Nicht so deren Reaktionen mit wir wissen von nichts.
Das ist.
Leicht produziere ich das jetzt so ein bisschen falsch. Ich meine, man kann immer noch sagen, sie waren ja verpflichtet offiziell von nichts zu wissen, aber es ist schon so ein bisschen,
schwierig, aber das, also ich will das jetzt nicht beschwören, also manche haben auf jeden Fall gesagt, dass es dass sie von nichts wüssten oder dass sie sich dessen nicht bewusst werden und keine Ahnung haben, wie denn dieser Zugriff habe erfolgen können,
Und äh in meiner schwachen Erinnerung war irgendwie Yahoo auch noch mit in dieser Liste. Also das wäre vielleicht nochmal ganz sinnvoll, das nachzu.
Also das stimmt, was hier, was ja, erste Reaktion auf die war, das weiß ich leider jetzt so auch nicht direkt und ähm da jetzt grade wegen Prison in den in den Medien ist, äh er ist auch die Google Suche nach die historische Google Suche.
Na, das ist ja eine, eine, eine, wie soll ich sagen, eine Collaboration Opportunity für unsere aufmerksamen äh Hörer? Ne, so sind kleine Hausaufgabe. Wir suchen jetzt nochmal die Yahoo-Reaktionen raus. Ein Jahrsnoten.
Dokumentiere recherchiere und bewerte die ganzen Pressemitteilungen wie sind diese im Lichte der neuesten Entwicklungen zu bewerten.
Aber handschriftlich Handschrift.
Nicht unter sechstausend Zeichen, maximal acht.
Einzureichen dann hier bitte in der Redaktion. Mhm. Na gut, äh ich glaube, das äh ist jetzt erschöpft das Thema oder? Genau. Ja.
Haben wir noch? Ja, Netz neutralisiert. Das Beste.
Netzzentraität. Ähm in den USA haben sich ja jetzt zudem zu der FCC ähm zu der anstehenden FCC Entscheidung. Inzwischen gibt's eine,
eine Rekordanzahl an äh Kommentaren zu zu ähm,
Zu dieser anstehenden Entscheidung. Äh das sind drei Millionen Kommentare. Ähm.
Ja und äh das das toppt ähm irgendwie die Kommentare zu äh Jenet Jacksons damals sogenannter äh.
Oder was?
Ja, wo ihre äh Kleidung äh versagt hat.
Was hackt.
Da gab's irgendwie eins Komma vier Millionen äh Beschwerden bei der FCC. Ich weiß nicht, ja. Äh das jetzt nur als kurze Meldung, dass da jetzt also ein Rekord äh gebrochen wurde.
Und da war jetzt auch in der letzten Woche dann äh oder vor ein paar Tagen der Slowdown DE,
wo also mehrere ähm Seiten.
Künstlich ihre, ihre Ladezeiten verlangsamt haben in mit so einem mit so einem äh getrickst du da, ne.
Das merkt man natürlich nicht in Deutschland.
War das äh war das auf Deutsch in Deutschland nicht so? Also.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe ehrlich gesagt heute Morgen das erste Mal vor diesem Slow Down Day überhaupt irgendwas gemerkt. Nicht, dass es nicht der ein oder andere Tag der letzten zwei Wochen im Prinzip für mich auch ein Slow Down Day gewesen wären, aber.
Nee, die haben äh die haben ja, also wenn ich das richtig erinnere
auch ich habe keine geslowdownte Seite gesehen, ähm haben sie das, haben sie jetzt nicht wirklich ihre Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit gedrosselt, sondern irgendwie so ein Java Skript über die Seite gehauen, die dann irgendwie so ein Ladesymbol.
Nach so was so ein bisschen danach aussieht, als ob irgendwas langsam lädt grade.
Ne, dass man das dann wegklicken kann, genauso wie beim Blackout Day, wo dann irgendwie ein ein leer schwarz drüber gelegt wurde, was man da auch nochmal weg.
Ja
Aber äh große, große Kampagne so und also Netzertraditat in den USA in in Anbetracht der bevorstehenden FCC,
Entscheidung ein ein großes Thema hier mit einem äh Rekord von drei Millionen Kommentare an die FCC. Wir hatten ja auch darüber berichtet, dass da der Ex-Lobby ist, der äh Vision jetzt irgendwie der,
Kopf der FCC ist und alles alles Riesenskandal. Ähm,
Und wir werden also sehen, wie sich das da entwickelt. Interessant finde ich, dass wir in Deutschland ja auch ähm eine eine kleine Entwicklung hatten, die wir hier erstmal gar nicht äh dokumentieren äh ja gar nicht kommentiert hatten, nämlich dass ähm,
Der gute Herr Oettinger, der neue EU-Kommissar für digitale Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft ist.
Hm, das vierte Fragezeichen.
Das ist das vierte Fragezeichen.
Ja. Ja.
Also das scheint noch nicht so ganz raus zu sein. Also er wurde auf jeden Fall ähm ich weiß gar nicht, wurde er schon in irgendeiner Form vorgeschlagen konkret oder ist das nur eine Dunkelliste, weil es ging ja da ein wenig.
Nee, der ist es jetzt. Er ist es jetzt. Das war erst äh äh Spekulation, aber der wird der wird das jetzt oder ist es, glaube ich sogar.
Okay, weil er war ja dann auch noch andere Ressourcen auf einmal im Gespräch. Das ist irgendwie noch aufgeteilt wird mit Internet und Innovation und Internet und Kultur und da war dann irgendwelche zypriotischen äh Kandidatinnen äh im Gespräch und aus Slowenien
das Feier ist alles ein bisschen verwirrend, aber wenn das jetzt auf Oettinger gefällt ist, dann ist das auf jeden Fall das vier Fragezeichen sind jetzt komplett, ne?
Und ähm tja.
Also der hat äh der war mal Ministerpräsident von Baden-Württemberg.
Dann seinen Job übernommen hat, weil er sich da bisschen sehr über alte Nazigrößen irgendwie übers Grab.
Zu viel äh Lob oder zu viel.
Wenig Kritik parat.
Ehemaligen Nazirichter, der
Todesurteile äh gefällt hat äh mehr oder weniger als äh das Vorbild des Widerstands gelobt so ungefähr an seinem Grabe. Das äh war dann schon ähm
sorgte damals für Kritik, diese Filbinger Geschichte war das, ne? Ähm Stuttgart einundzwanzig Fans äh sind sicherlich auch äh große Freunde,
Von Öttinger, dann wurde er irgendwann mal noch durch den Kakao gezogen, als er dann in Richtung EU äh wegbefördert wurde, hat er, glaube ich, dann irgendwie mal äh ein Interview versucht zu geben auf Englisch, was dann auch nochmal viral wurde,
wo er dann irgendwie so ein ähnlich, also ja, immerhin, im Gegensatz zu äh Westerwave hat das ja äh wenigstens versucht, ja.
Wenigstens.
Aber ähm also eine eine ein ein klassischer und streitbarer Vertreter der Christ äh Demokraten,
und ähm zudem wir aber natürlich deshalb äh uns noch nicht geäußert haben, weil wir erstmal die Inhalte abwarten wollten, welche er denn da vertritt. Und äh stellt sich heraus, er ist also ganz klar für die Netzneutralität,
Ganz klar. Müsste man halt nur mal abstufen.
Na, Tante ist ja alles gut.
Abgestufte Netzneutralität.
Oh großartig.
Gibt's einen einen großen Artikel in der Wirtschaftswoche. Kritik an Oettinger ist fehl am Platz. Ähm wo er dann äh,
ähm,
Auch dabei geht es um Regulierung, aber vor allem um Netzneutralität. Öttinger lässt bereits durchblicken, dass er eine abgestufte Netz- und Neutralität einer absoluten vorzieht. Ähm,
ja und da wird er also, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was dann so die abgestufte Netznetralität ist. Ähm,
kann natürlich nix sein, aber das äh kann natürlich keine Netzneutralität mehr sein, weil es eben genau keine Klassen und keine Abstufungen äh bei der Netzneutralität gibt. Ähm,
Aber was sehr sehr interessant vor dem Hintergrund ist, ähm fand ich die Einlassung,
eines Sprechers der Deutschen Telekom, die jetzt äh heute oder gestern, heute, bei äh heise DE dokumentiert wurde,
wo er sagt, Netzneutralität ist in Wahrheit die Privilegierung amerikanischer Konzerne.
Ja? Also das Argument, das ist eines der wirtschaftlichen Kernargumente für die Netzzentralität ist ja, dass es groß, dass.
Ein Bruch der Netzneutralität ist großen,
Anbietern ermöglichen wird, kleine Konkurrenten auszustechen,
und zwar in dem die äh großen Netzanbieter direkte Deals mit die großen Content-Anbieter, direkte Deals mit den großen Netzanbietern machen zu ihrer,
zur Bevorteiligung ihres eigenen Traffics und kleinere Konkurrenten dazu nicht in der Lage sein werden. Diese äh finanziellen ähm,
diese finanziellen äh Lasten auf sich zu nehmen. Das heißt, ein ein am Markt wohl etablierter Anbieter, nennen wir ihn mal Netflix,
könnte sich, sofern eine Netznetralität nicht durch Regulation erzwungen ist. Ähm,
Quasi Konkurrenz vom Leib halten.
Indem ihr einfach ein ausreichend großes Stück von seinem eigenen Kuchen mit den äh mit den Leitungsanbietern, mit den Internetservice Providern teilt,
Und das ist ja eigentlich das, worum's die ganze Zeit geht. So und jetzt sagt die Telekom,
oder ähm wie heißt Philipp Lang von der Telekom sagt ähm also ist ganz schön, er er erklärt die ganze Zeit. Ja äh unsere Branche äh schrumpft, während wir die ganze Zeit investieren müssen, ja ähm,
Also schrumpfen heißt ja der Gewinn schrumpft, ne? Also äh er verplappert sich, dass es ihm natürlich eigentlich um den Gewinn geht. Und dann beklagt er sich erstmal darüber, äh die Kosten für den Infrastruktur ähm,
Ausbau tragen fast ausschließlich die Endkunden. Das stimmt natürlich nicht. Im Moment trägt seinen Gewinn die noch. Ja, aber okay. Ähm,
Kommen wir zu der zu der Kernargumentation, wer sagt und weil sie auf die sogenannte Netzneutralität eingehen. Die Telekom steht für das freie und offene Internet, in dem keiner diskriminiert wird. Heute haben aber große
Internetunternehmen die Möglichkeit, die Qualität ihrer Dienste durch weltweite Serverparks zu verbessern, weil sie die Inhalte näher zu den Kunden bringen.
Kleine Unternehmen haben diese Möglichkeit nicht. Ähm ich habe ja, ich habe ja äh wir haben wir haben ja sogar gemeinsame Freunde, die äh quasi im Internet arbeiten, also am am und im Internet ähm,
Und da habe ich mir mal erklären lassen, jetzt Netflix macht tatsächlich genau das. Die Stellen ihres Server, quasi ähm in den einzelnen Ländern irgendwie so nah wie möglich an den Six dran.
Ja, man nennt das einen Content Distribution Network.
Genau. Ackermai, mach das, ne, dass du der größte Amazon macht das.
Google macht das.
Google macht das alle machen, dass die Knallen ihre Server natürlich nicht nur an eine Stelle.
Apple auch.
Genau. Ähm bei Netflix ist es sogar so, wie ich erfahren habe, was ich sehr interessant finde, wenn du als ISP groß genug bist.
Das äh Netflix sagt, yo, in euer äh System geht so viel rein,
Das macht Sinn, wenn wir uns wirklich bei euch nochmal reinstellen, dann stellt Netflix quasi eine einen Server von sich,
ein Schrank oder was auch immer, wie viel groß das dann ist. Bei dem Provider selber hin und Netflix zahlt die Büchs und der Profider zahlt den Strom.
Das heißt, es wäre jetzt also denkbar, dass äh Netflix eine eine,
frei Haus an die Deutsche Telekom liefert mit der Empfehlung äh diese bei der Deutschen Telekom ins äh ins Datenrechnen, was weiß ich, was Zentrum zu stellen, um äh die Kunden eben
um den Kunden einen vernünftigen Dienst zu erbringen und die Telekom muss dann eben nur den Strom dafür zahlen.
Fand ich mal äh fand ich mal ganz interessant.
Ja, ich verstehe diese Logik, ehrlich gesagt, noch nicht so ganz, wovon sie jetzt hier eigentlich alle reden. Also.
Das ist ja auch keine Logik. Das ist ja auch totaler Unsinn, was er redet.
Ja, es ist.
Totaler Unsinn. Er sagt, was als Netzneutralität verkauft wird, ist in Wahrheit die Privilegierung großer amerikanischer Internetkonzerne und zwar zu Lasten von Startups. Hat nur mit Netzneutralität gar nichts zu tun. Ähm.
Ja, weil er redet ja von Serverparks und nicht von Durchleitungen, ne? Und das ist halt wirklich mal was komplett anderes.
Genau, das ist äh äh ist etwas komplett.
Außerdem, natürlich kann auch ein kleines Unternehmen ein Serverpark aufbauen. Das tun sie in der Regel auch bloß vielleicht nicht ganz so große und nicht ganz so viele, wenn sie nicht so viele Kunden haben, ist das ja auch vollkommen normal, aber nichts hindert sie daran, das zu tun.
Was kleine Unternehmen machen, ist sie mieten sich Instanzen bei Amazon.
Oder bei Ackermai.
Machen, große äh Unternehmen ja auch so, also Dropbox speichert wenn ich mich nicht äh täusche, auch heute noch auf äh Amazon S3. Ja, das heißt.
Und so weiter, sogar Apple, also alle äh sind,
gegenseitig da ähm Ressourcen einkaufen. Wie's halt irgendwie sinnvoll ist, weil wenn ich jetzt kein eigenes Serverzentrum habe, dann ist halt für mich besser. Ich kaufe das bei irgendeinem Dienstleister ein, der eben genau das verkauft, nämlich entweder,
breite nah am Kunden, an bestimmten Netzen, Festplattenkapazität, Webserverkapazität, Pipapo bis hin zu eben kompletten Host und Rechnern und et cetera wie das ja auch für jeden offen
Offen steht bei Anbietern wie wissen schon, wer jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber man geht halt einfach hin und klickt sich eine
das ist die Cloud, das ist irgendwie das, was wir alle benutzen und hier steckt überhaupt,
Besonderes drin und ich sehe auch überhaupt nicht, warum jetzt ein großer Konzern da einen anderen Zugang hat. Natürlich, wenn die mehr Geld äh in die Hand nehmen, dann können sie sich damit mehr, mehr kaufen, aber das ist ja nicht das, was
Neutralität hier irgendwie greift. Also ich sehe in dieser ganzen Debatte auch schon wieder so, jetzt wird schon wieder so der Google, ja, so äh als
Das Böse äh hingestellt, ja, was vielleicht auch teilweise sein mag, aber sicherlich nicht in dem in der Hinsicht, über die wir jetzt hier darüber äh sprechen.
Also das das Entlarvene Zitat ist natürlich an der Stelle, wie gesagt, ja, unsere Branche schrumpft und wir müssen immer mehr investieren. Ja, das da
das ist das harte Los, was du als Infrastrukturanbieter hast, ja, da musst du eben nicht dann hätten wir die, die Internetinfrastruktur eben niemals an solche äh Vögel privatisieren sollen, sondern uns da ernsthaft drum kümmern sollen, dass wir sagen, okay, das äh wie du schon immer, ich zitiere es sehr gerne.
Äh Stromwasser, Internet ähm,
Es ist bereitzustellen, hat auch irgendwie noch gibt keinen dokumentierten Fall, dass das irgendwie zum Vorteil äh der der Wasserverbraucher oder ähm zu irgendeinem anderen Vorteil gewesen wäre, ähm derartige Versorgung zu privatisieren, ja.
Profitinteressen zu unterwerfen. Ähm,
Insofern, ja, diese diese Branche sollte schrumpfen, das ist, sollte eigentlich erklärtes, politisches Ziel sein, dass diese Branche schrumpft, nämlich indem sie immer mehr investiert,
und immer weniger einnimmt und irgendwann wir eine vernünftige Infrastruktur haben.
Ja? Also das wäre jetzt so die die Hoffnung, ne? Straßenbau äh in in Deutschland äh irgendwann auch mal einen großen Anteil äh der Steuerkosten wahrscheinlich verschlungen, als der ganze äh Teppich ausgelegt wurde. Und jetzt wird er noch ein bisschen gepflegt. Jetzt wird in jedes ähm,
in jedes Schlagloch noch ein bisschen heiße Teer reingegossen und die die Kosten sind insgesamt ein bisschen äh geringer. Ähm.
Ja, also es ist mir auch irgendwie unverständlich, wie so auch ein Land, was irgendwie zum Beispiel damals mit Kabelfernsehen auch äh eine entsprechende Infrastruktur auf äh Riss gemacht hat, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes in Deutschland. Da ging das ja auch. Und auf einmal hatte man überall,
Fernsehinfrastruktur. Kann man auch mit Internet machen.
Man, aber ähm ökonomische Zwänge stehen dem im Moment entgegen, weil wir können ja nicht hinnehmen, dass deren Branche schrumpft.
Okay, also auf jeden Fall das vierte Fragezeichen macht jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, dass es jetzt ein neues Lied singt, sondern da wird jetzt im Wesentlichen äh äh das der anderen Amseln mit
gesungen und äh wir müssen halt abwarten, bis diese Kommission denn auch tatsächlich mal ernannt ist, weil das ist sie ja noch nicht. Das ist ja jetzt alles erstmal Vorschläge und das muss vom Parlament dann auch abgesegnet werden, so sind die Regeln und das Parlament hat das noch nicht getan, aber das Parlament hat auch, glaube ich,
dicken Hals, was bisher so die ganzen Personalien betrifft, das betrifft jetzt,
nicht nur und auch gar nicht vor allem Oettinger, sondern auch andere äh Konstellationen, wo man dann halt die äh entsprechenden Lobbyismus derzeit ähm ähm Vormarsch erwähnt, äh ist noch nicht absehbar
die neue Kommission wirklich einsatzfähig ist, wir werden das beobachten.
Mir konnten wir wollten noch kurz zwei Sachen zu den großen Content-Anbietern und Content durch sagen. Ähm,
jetzt äh vor kurzem ein interessanten Gespräch gelernt, die ähm.
Amazon und AkamaCloud sind im Moment ähm die beste beziehungsweise beliebteste Möglichkeit zum Umgehen der Great Firewall of China. Weil,
inzwischen so viel Content posten.
Dass sie's nicht sperren können. Das heißt, äh zur Zensurumgehung ist das Ausweichen auf diese großen äh CDNs äh im Moment eine eine sehr äh.
Sobald die also eine komplexe URL und IP-Adressenstruktur haben, die sich überhaupt nicht sinnvoll blockieren lässt, weil da es auch vollkommen unklar ist, was wo jetzt rauskommt. Ah, interessant.
Ganz interessanter äh Aspekt und der andere ist,
Dass man ja mal darüber, dass wir dann wahrscheinlich auch mal darüber nachdenken müssen, wenn wir jetzt alle nur noch in diese großen Content-Anbieter gehen, das ist ja auch nicht eine ähm,
eine ähm Entwicklung, die man unbedingt als positiv bezeichnen muss,
wenn man einen Verfechter äh dezentraler, offener Netz ist, weil ein Cent, also irgendwie den größeren Teil des Internet-Contents in äh,
in diese Cloud-Anbieter zu werfen, wo es dann wiederum deren äh,
potenziellen äh zensurregime unterliegt ist wahrscheinlich in nur in Nuancen unter ein Unterschied zu der Abschaffung einer äh einer Netzneutralität durch die äh
ähm äh Dienst, Internetservice Provider.
Das so nur als am am Rande. Also das ist auch nicht besonders positive Entwicklung.
Ist mal wieder aufgewacht.
Ja, die haben ähm.
Zweierlei Hinsicht. Jetzt kommt erstmal die erster Hinsicht.
Ah ja genau, es kommt ja noch eine zweite äh ja sie haben,
mal eine Analyse gemacht, dieser dieses Finn, dieses Gamma League, von dem wir, glaube ich, schon vor zwei, drei äh Folgen berichtet hatten, wo ich ja auch mal so drin rumgeschaut habe und damals auch schon, glaube ich,
angekündigt habe, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass sich dabei mal jemand wirklich mit auseinandersetzt und wirklich analysiert, weil es ja die Kunden und Support-Datenbank umfasste. Und ich äh
mit meinen äh geringen Hintergrundwissen über diese Firmen, da ja schon einige Länder dann ähm,
identifizieren konnte, von denen wir nicht hundertprozentig klar war, ob da jetzt schon bewiesen war, dass die äh eben Finn, Fischer als äh Staatstrojaner einsetzen oder nicht und ähm ja, das äh diese Analyse ähm,
Hätte eigentlich eher gedacht, dass das Citizen Lab die macht, aber WikiLeaks äh schien an der Stelle jetzt ähm,
zu sein, wobei es von Citisen Lab auch eine Veröffentlichung gab. Kommen wir zum Thema äh Wiki Leaks schätzt das Auftragsvolumen von ähm,
von Gamma auf fünfzig Millionen Euro Lizenzgebühren. Ja? Ähm.
Aber auf welcher Basis diese Schätzung jetzt erfolgt ist, ist auch nicht so ganz klar.
Äh in dieser Datenbank zu deren Support-Server gibt es quasi eine ähm Kunden ähm.
Liste. Diese Kunden haben aber alle immer quasi so,
Acht äh extra Dezimalcharakter als Nutzername und dann irgendwie so zweiunddreißig random carectors als Passwort äh beziehungsweise das ist natürlich dann als gehasht, aber einige haben sie wohl gecrackt,
ähm und das heißt, die haben im Prinzip anonyme Kunden,
Das heißt, selbst aus diesem Lead konntest du nicht wirklich wissen, in welchem Land der jeweilige Kunde sitzt. Aber in der.
Anonyme Kunden aber anonymisierte Kunden.
Anonymisierte Kundenaccounts für ihr Supportforum. Aber zu den einzelnen Kunden war da drin genau verzeichnet, welche Lizenzen die haben.
Das heißt, sie konnten jetzt quasi äh schätzen, aha, so und so für die Lizenzen beiverkauft,
Lizenzpreis wissen, wie er ist, ungefähr so und so hoch. Rechnen war mal ein Rabatt mit ein. Ähm dann gab's noch andere Produkte wie eben Finn ISP, also das Gerät, was beim Internetprovider in den in den Schrank gestellt wird und dort genau das tut, was wir gerade
den NSA für die Satelliten links äh unterstellt haben, nämlich ähm Traffic umleiten und manipulieren, also zum Beispiel aus deinem
Betriebssystem-Update eine Installation zu machen,
und ähnliches. Ähm da ist der Preis nicht bekannt. Ja, sodass dann da teilweise auch Preise äh geschätzt werden mussten.
Okay, aber das von der Größenordnung her halten wir uns daran mal fest.
Genau, Großkunde, die Mongolei, derzeit geschäftsführendes Land der Freedom Onlinekoalition
Äh Singapur äh spricht in einer Support-Anfrage explizit von hundertfünfzig Diszidenten und anderen Zielen, die überwacht werden sollen ähm
Da wurde also äh nochmal schön schön recherchiert, sehr äh,
elegant ähm vorher wurde das gesamte Geschäfts der Gamma Group auf äh zwanzig Millionen geschätzt und äh Wikileaks geht jetzt von fünfzig Millionen aus und bezeichnet die,
Schätzung als konservativ. Auch veröffentlicht haben sie eine bisher nicht öffentlich erhältliche Binary, der äh Finn Fischer,
ähm also quasi ein die.
Software selber.
Fin Fisher Echse, den Trojaner selber, so, ja.
Das war aber nicht Teil dieses Hacks, oder?
Na ja, da wird's spannend. Ähm Teil dieses Hacks waren teilweise per äh zippverschlüsselte, teilweise per äh PGP verschlüsselte,
Dateien, die darauf hinwiesen, dass sich darin Finn Fischer Versionen befanden.
Na ja, wenn es irgendwie so Finn Fischer Punkt V1 Punkt drei, Exe Punkt GPG heißt, also so in der Art waren die Dateiname. Also es gab ähm
gab da mehrere Dateien drin, auch eine eine sehr große verschlüsselte Zip-Datei und er stellt sich jetzt die Frage.
Ob die Dateien daher stammen oder nicht. Das habe ich jetzt, habe ich wiederum noch nicht zurückrecherchiert, ob's ob der Hinweis dieser Dateinamen irgendwie,
dahin deutet, dass Wiki Leaks diese Verschlüsselung geknackt hat. Ähm ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wenn es aber das jetzt Mutmaßungen, weil ich's nicht mir genau angeschaut habe, ähm,
dass sich eine der äh verwendeten Zip-Dateien vielleicht,
nicht AES-Verschlüsselte war, sondern das alte den alten PKZ Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus genutzt hat, der
nointextangriffen etwas schutzlos gegenüber stand und wenn man dann mal ein paar von Wiki Leaks Bitcoins in Dollar umwandelt und sich eine
Grafikkarten oder sonst was, Instanz in der Amazon-Cloud mietet
und die mal drei Tage warmlaufen lässt, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man da eine gewisse Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit hat, dass so eine Datei daraus fällt. Ähm.
Aber die ist immer noch relativ klein, diese Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit. Ähm
wegen und ich gehe in den eigentlich nicht davon aus, wenn man so das allgemeine, die bei Gamada äh gewaltet hat, anschaut, dass das jetzt so unbedingt,
Passwörter gewesen wären, die in dem Rahmen sind, dass man da noch was knacken kann. Also irgendwie hat Wikillix da, entweder eine andere Quelle oder
besonders gut recherchiert um so eine Datei zu knacken. Ähm nichts genaues weiß man nicht, aber es ist natürlich zu begrüßen,
Dass diese Datei gelingt ist, weil sie entsprechend natürlich jetzt sofort von allen Virenscannern wieder äh entdeckt wird. Und das äh dem ganzen Geschäftsmodell von Gamma, hoffentlich ein größeres ähm,
ein größeres Problem, einbrockt.
Wobei, wie wir in der Sendung mit Ulf besprochen hatten, sie ja ohnehin irgendwie sechs Monate Garantie auf ihre äh geben, was bedeutet, dass sie eh immer noch ein paar in petto zu haben scheinen.
Ja, aber jede, jedes äh League einer solchen Datei ist äh positiv, weil es eben ähm,
unabhängigen äh Forschern die Möglichkeit gibt, äh das funktionieren dieses Trojaners mehr und mehr zu analysieren. Äh Heuristiken dafür zu schaffen,
und äh hoffentlich äh ja das äh,
Vertrauen der Staaten in Gamma zu schwächen und gleichzeitig ähm den Preis für Gamma äh dieses Produkt anbieten zu können, eben massiv in die Höhe zu treiben.
Das war's zu dem Thema. Mir fällt da jetzt nichts mehr zu ein. Ich weiß.
Nehmen wir auch nicht, also da wird noch, da wird noch ein bisschen was kommen. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass jetzt noch Analysen dieser dieser Fin Fischer Trojaner folgen werden. Und wie gesagt, noch mal kurz der Hinweis, woher jetzt genau diese Dateien stammen, absolute Spekulation von mir.
Auf jeden Fall, dass du zumindest in dieser WikiLeaks-Bewegung auch,
konkrete Aktivitäten nach wie vor äh stattfinden und das mal zu reagieren in der Lage ist oder zumindest Leut bereit sind, ihre Tätigkeit, die sie da ausüben, so oder so äh unter das Wikileaks-Label zu stellen, was man auch mal davon halten mag.
Ja oder der Julio hat halt Zeit, ne?
Macht das selber?
Weiß ich nicht. Ähm ich hätt's gerne selber gemacht, aber ich habe halt keine Zeit.
Ja, wolltet ihr nicht raus? Er wollte doch raus.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der raus will. Der hatte das.
Meinst du, wer schießt? Der hatte ja angekündigt, dass er da bald rausgeht, aber ähm.
Nicht gesagt wann.
Ja, ähm interessant übrigens, das war äh Gregor Sedlerkatteln im in einem anderen Podcast mal darauf hingewiesen, das hatten wir hier noch nicht so explizit gesagt, deswegen will ich das gerne nochmal zitieren, dass er sagt, also,
dass der Mann voll seit den Snowden Enthüllung, ja, seitdem irgendwie die enge Zusammenarbeit zwischen äh GCAQ
und NSA und überhaupt der Kooperation bekannt ist, ja?
Kann er doch im Zweifelsfall die Behauptung, dass Schweden eine größere Bedrohung für seine äh,
dass ihm in Schweden ein größeres Risiko der Auslieferung drohe, als ausgerechnet in Großbritannien ähm kaum noch aufrechterhalten. Das fand ich ein sehr äh,
wichtigen Hinweis an der Stelle, den wir, glaube ich, so explizit noch nicht so in einem Satz so schön mal hatten, deswegen.
Ja, kann sein, dass wir das so nicht erwähnt haben.
Du hattest, du hattest das in in längeren äh Sätzen schon mal formuliert.
Setzen. Na gut, kommen wir weg von den Bandwurmsitzen und zu Kurzmeldungen.
Genau. Äh letzte Woche noch brandheiße Meldung. Äh uh, das das Eilverbot von Uber, ja, die einen, die einstweilige Verfügung, die den Betrieb von äh Uber untersagt hat. Ähm
Jetzt schon wieder einkassiert vom Landgericht Frankfurt. Ähm und zwar mit dem,
mit mit einer interessanten äh Begründung, nämlich für eine einstweilige ähm Verfügung ist ja.
Diese Eile, das Entscheidende, also das Rechtsmittel der einstweiligen Verfügung gibt es,
um einem wahrscheinlich,
von einem Gericht getroffenen Urteil schnell zuvorkommen zu können, wenn irgendwie akute Gefahr besteht. Also Beispiel ähm.
Unwiederbringliche äh Fakten geschafft werden. So, wenn man.
Genau, also du, sagen wir mal, du, was wäre denn jetzt mal so ein Beispiel? Ich habe einen einen Pop-Song aufgenommen
und du ähm verbreitest den über Meterebene Punkt ME, ja? Dann kann ich dich irgendwie an äh anzeigen wegen Verletzung meines Urheberrechtes und so weiter. Ich kann aber auch
eine oder ich kann schnell eine einstweilige Verfügung gegen dich erwirken, weil du ja durch das Bereitstellen dieses,
meines Pop-Songs auf Metaebene ME,
ein ein weitergehender Schaden entsteht. Ja und dann dann wird quasi ein schnell, einstweilig verfügt. Tim muss das runternehmen, dann kriegst du ein, zwei Verfügung. Dann kannst du dir entweder entsprechen,
oder es kommt eben zum Gerichtsverfahren.
Und wenn du, äh wenn es dann zum Gerichtsverfahren kommt, dann kriegst du's halt entweder doppelt auf den Sack oder ich. Das ist quasi so ein äh im im äh im im in dem juristischen Duell, ja?
Aber das Entscheidende ist eben, dass es irgendwie eine Dringlichkeit geben muss,
und das eine anhaltende Rechtsverletzung äh da eben eingestellt werden muss und zwar so schnell wie möglich. So und jetzt hat der,
der Richter Frowin Kurt vom äh Landgericht Frankfurt gesagt, na ja.
So dringend waren wir's war's jetzt doch nicht.
So dringend war's nicht, weil Uber operiert ja immerhin seit einem Jahr und keiner äh ist irgendwie nennenswert äh zu Schaden gekommen oder,
Ja und sagt, das kann also auf jeden Fall mal zu einem,
ordentlichen ähm das kann noch auf ein ordentliches Hauptverfahren warten diese Angelegenheit. Geht aber da trotzdem aus, dass ähm,
In der Sache diese Entscheidung äh richtig war. Also er sagt, Uber ist wahrscheinlich im Unrecht
aber es ist keine Dringlichkeit geboten, deswegen kassieren wir mal diese einstweiligen Verfügungen ein, äh die ja mit zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro Ordnungsgeld pro vermittelter Fahrt gedroht hat, was so viel ist wie Yahoo, in Dollar bezahlt hätte,
pro Tag, ja, aber ähm Uber hier pro Fahrt,
das wäre ja also sie hätten das im Prinzip einen Tag lang machen können, dann wären sie, hätten sie ihr Venture, Kapitel da äh sicherlich verbraten,
Egal, also das wurde jetzt wieder eingesagt. Man kann also schön weiter.
Ja, bei unserer Bundesregierung findet ja auch sowieso, dass da äh keinerlei,
wie soll ich sagen, also Heiko Maas in der Bundesjustizminister äh hat sich ja dazu geäußert und meint, wir würden so das nicht so allzu problematisch ansehen mit Uber.
Dem Richter,
Aber das ist so in gewissen Dissenz zwischen der ähm Justiz und die Bundesregierung gibt's jetzt auch nix Neues. Jetzt muss man halt abwarten, was dabei rauskommt. Alles, was wir zum Thema Sharing und so weiter gesagt haben, gilt nach wie vor und äh wir können das nur abwarten.
Ein, ein interessanter Aspekt, der den ich dann heute noch so auf Twitter sah, war ähm,
sollte sich jetzt irgendwie einer eine Art Rechtsstatus für diese Oberfahrer etablieren. Ähm.
Dann können die auch ihre Karre absetzen,
Das heißt, dann wäre das unter Umständen, also jetzt hier wieder. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Steuern, also ähm ich versuche meine Steuererklärung immer zu machen, aber ich kriege dann meistens kriege ich Ärger. Ähm,
Ich lerne da also learning by doing, ne,
Aber ich weiß, dass man versuchen kann, Dinge abzusetzen und dass das unter Umständen ganz interessant ist, Dinge abzusetzen und vielleicht werde ich dann Uberfahrer ähm setze meinen VW-Bus ab und fahre irgendwie einmal äh im einmal im Jahr irgendwie den Tim als irgendwie zur Kita, den,
Kinder abholen und oder so, ne? Ne, mal gucken. Also da da das Thema bleibt also auch interessant.
Zum nächsten Thema.
Das nächste Thema auch nur ganz eine eine schöne, interessante Randmeldung und zwar vor allem, weil wir das äh in unseren Betrachtungen des Leistungsschutzrechts uns immer auch nur so auf Google,
konzentriert haben,
Stefan Niggemeier, der Medien äh Journalist vermeldet, dass äh mehrere Suchmaschinen jetzt Verlagsseiten nicht mehr anzeigen und zwar äh Web DE, GMX oder T Online,
haben im Prinzip die gesamten Mitglieder der VG Media aus ihren Suchmaschinen rausgeworfen.
Das ist so großartig.
Ja, also äh ähm Welt DE, Bild DE, HAZ, also Hannoversche Allgemeine Zeitung
Abendblatt, Mopo, also irgendwie die ganzen Leute, ja. Inhalte anderer Verlage, nicht Geld für die Anzeige, kurze Ausschrittierer, Inhalte in Suchmaschinen oder Aggregatoren verlangen, werden nach wie vor angezeigt.
Ja ähm das heißt denen sind natürlich jetzt die äh also jetzt wird's irgendwie,
Spannend, ja.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist ja dieser klassische so äh Moment, ja, mal schauen, wie das anhält, aber das war ja immer sozusagen eine der Thesen
sicherlich auch mehr als einmal geäußert haben, dass dieses Leistungsrecht ja irgendwie sinnlos ist und äh,
Eigentlich am Ende ja nur dazu führen kann, dass äh all diese Unternehmen einfach rausfliegen aus diesem Index. Ja, man muss sich einfach immer nur mal wieder klarmachen, worum es geht. Die,
Im Wesentlichen regen sich ja alle darüber auf, dass es Google News gibt und auf ihre Webseiten verlinkt. Und alle so,
Ja, das ist sozusagen ein Aggregator, der euch Kunden zuspült. Dafür wollten sie dann Geld haben
Haben sie sich dieses Leistungsschutzrecht irgendwie erkauft, um quasi einen Rechtsanspruch auf Geld zu bekommen, dafür, dass man Kunden geschickt bekommt, nicht? Schöner Taxivergleich. Und jetzt äh
droht sozusagen, dass die dann sagen, na ja, also wenn wir dafür bezahlen sollen, dass wir euch Kunden geben, dann ist irgendwie die Welt irgendwie falsch rum, dann lassen wir das halt auch einfach sein. Genau das passiert jetzt, zwar noch nicht mit Google News,
sondern eben mit den kleineren, ja? Ich fand das immer doppelt absurd, dass sie irgendwie ihnen auch immer vorgeworfen haben, dass sie da irgendwas ausnutzen, weil auf Google News bis zum heutigen Tag keiner
Werbung steht. Das ist einfach kein.
Aber jetzt, das, das haben wir wiederholt jetzt.
Ja, ja klar, aber das, ich meine, das ist jetzt so lange her. Ich glaube, das hat jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jeder nochmal äh so äh im Kopf. Ich finde das jetzt nochmal ganz wertvoll, das so zusammenzufassen,
Es sei denn
irgendwie, sie würden es irgendwie schaffen, jetzt äh mit dieser Rechtslage äh auch noch die Unternehmen dazu zu zwingen. Und genau das ist ja nun gescheitert. Ja, also hatten wir letztes Mal, glaube ich, ne, dass äh die VW Medien einfach jetzt komplett gescheitert sind mit ihrem Vorschlag, wo dann einfach das Kartellamt und meinte so, habt ihr sie noch alle?
Und jetzt äh kommt die Reaktion und jetzt wird halt irgendwie gekillt und ich frage mich, wie lange es noch dauert, bis Google killt.
Ja noch äh was, mir fallen ja noch zwei interessante Dinge zu ein. Diese ganzen,
Web DE GMX DE und T Online, ne? Also hier online ist ja schon immer noch einer der größten Provider und die die Leute, die die die dessen Kunden sind, landen, glaube ich, auch wenn sie deren Software installieren auf dieser T-Oline-Seite. Also es sind ähm,
glaube ich, weitgehend,
unterschätzte Portale, weil die meisten Menschen ja auch diesen etwas komischen anhängen, Webmail zu lesen. Das heißt, die lesen also E-Mail.
Über HTML Interfaces,
in Provider bereitstellen, zum Beispiel GMX äh Web DE und T Online. Und auf diesen Seiten macht Web DE natürlich äh und und und GMX, machen da auch so so News,
Panorama, hier äh ist auch was passiert. Äh DPA-Meldung, haste nicht gesehen.
Solche Sachen. Aber schön fand ich, also das sind, glaube ich, relativ unterschätzte Portale, was äh was Traffic oder so angeht. Aber besonders schön finde ich, dass der Stefan Ningemeier noch eine Antwort von der äh von äh T-Online bekommen hat.
Die VG Media und die Deutsche Telekom haben sich in der letzten Zeit über die Lizensierung der Leistungsschutzrechte von denjenigen Presseverlegern ausgetauscht,
die von der VG Media vertreten werden. Man konnte sich allerdings nicht einigen. Die Deutsche Telekom hat sich daher bis auf Weiteres entschlossen,
ab Ende Juli zweitausendvierzehn die entsprechenden Suchergebnisse auf ihren Portalen so darstellen zu lassen, dass sie eindeutig dicht unter das Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseerzeugnisse, der von der VG Media vertretenen Presseverlage fallen.
Also nicht. Sie zeigen sie halt gar nicht an.
Ja, das ist der einzige grad an Eindeutigkeit, den man noch herstellen kann. So viel zum Thema Rechtsunsicherheit.
Genau, ja. Äh wunderbar, das,
Ja. Fand ich, finde ich ganz schlimm. Hätte man gar nicht vermutet, dass bei der was äh das bei T Online äh und so, da da tatsächlich noch irgendwie jemand sitzt, der Humor hat, ne, aber haben die.
Nicht nur bei Lokbuch.
Ja und jetzt kommen wir zu der zweiten.
Genau, die haben auch viel Humor.
Wir schalten nach Neuseeland, wo äh,
Unser Spezialfreund Kimbel schon seit Unwesen treibt und äh unter anderem wohl auch die ein oder andere Mark gemacht hat äh äh vor allem mit seinem Portal Mega,
Upload einer dieser
ominösen Upload Provider, wo man dann halt irgendwie Zeug hochladen kann auf das andere Leute es herunterladen, nachweislich ist da halt eine ganze Menge und äh Copy reitet äh materiell äh drüber gelaufen. Ich glaube, das äh bestreitet niemand.
Und ähm irgendwann kam dann mal äh Hollywood und hat äh alles in Bewegung gesetzt, um seine habhaft äh zu werden. Da gab's dann diesen schönen Raid, wo sie dann irgendwie auf seinen ähm,
pompöses äh Anwesenden in Neuseeland da eingeritten sind und ihn irgendwie da aus der Schreikammer rausgezogen haben,
saß er eine Weile irgendwie im Knast und wurde halt ähm vor Gericht gestellt und ist dann,
In der Folge dann aber wieder wegen Formfehlern ist das Ganze wieder fallen gelassen worden. Es ging dann immer so ein bisschen hin und her. Äh zuletzt war, glaube ich, auch noch,
die die Entscheidung, ob er sein Geld wiederbekommt, das habe ich jetzt gerade gar nicht gespeichert, wie das ausgegangen ist.
Ein großer Teil seines Vermögens wurde da beschlagnahmt und ähm.
Und das hat er jetzt, glaube ich, auch teilweise wiederbekommen. Ich da bin ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen äh auf dünn Eis.
Also grundsätzlich hat er mehrere ganz interessante Erfolge gegen vor Gericht, gegen eben die gegnerischen Anwälte und die USA, die seiner werden wollen, irgendwie erstritten. Das kann man, glaube ich, so zusammen.
Sein
wie soll ich sagen, sein Image in Neuseeland können wir schwer einschätzen, in Deutschland ähm können wir es äh etwas besser einschätzen, ist sagen wir mal gelinde gesagt, etwas schwierig,
es ist eben dann aber doch sehr in die Hände gespielt worden durch die ganze Snowden-Affäre, da ist er dann schnell auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen und er hat ja ohnehin so ein bisschen schon immer so den Trend gehabt, sich als der Befreier äh des Netzes und um überhaupt der
Heiland äh des äh digitalen ähm darzustellen. Da muss man sich nur mal so seine ganzen selbst produzierten Musikvideos et cetera äh anschauen. Also äh er war ja auch noch nie jemand, der
wie soll ich sagen, die Zurückhaltung besonders kultiviert hat.
Äh vielleicht noch ein kurzer nochmal kurze äh kurze Exkurs wie diese mega äh Upload Rapid Share und äh was nicht alles, wie wie solche Anbieter funktioniert haben oder funktionieren. Die Idee war.
Zu sagen, ja, wenn eine Datei zu groß ist, dass sie die per E-Mail verschicken kannst.
Auch ein durchaus giltender Fakt ist so.
Genau. Dann lädst du die bei uns hoch und dann kriegst du von uns einen Link zu dieser Datei. Der Link ist relativ lang und ob's Kur. Und es gibt keinen zentralen Index, welche Dateien bei uns liegen.
Ähm was super ist, ne, nimmst eine Datei, lädst die bei bei irgendwie bei mega Upload oder was hoch, also weil das gibt's jetzt, glaube ich, nicht mehr, lädt sie da hoch
fällt ein Link raus, steht drin
Äh irgendwie dieser Teil bleibt hier bis irgendwann dreißig Tage lang keiner mehr drauf zugegriffen hat, dann löschen wir die. Die Link schickst du an den Empfänger und der lädt die Datei runter. Ähm,
so und dann gleich dreißig Tage keiner mehr drauf zu und dann wird der da gelöscht, ne. Wenn aber jetzt natürlich sehr viele darauf zugreifen, dann bleibt die Datei dort. Ähm
und wenn die Datei besonders groß ist, dann wird mega Upload den Downloadern dann sagen, ja, guck mal, das ist eine sehr große Datei. Du kannst jetzt entweder lange warten auf den Download und ihn dann langsam machen oder du,
kaufst bei uns so ein so ein zehn Euro Ding, dann äh pro Monat, dann kriegst du irgendwie so und so viel Gigabit. Äh so und so viel äh Gigabyte zu Highspeed zum downloaden und so.
Und dann gab's eben das komplementäre Angebot dazu. Das waren dann solche Foren, in denen ähm,
getauscht wurden und der Link führte dann immer zu Megaupload und quasi das oder eben anderen und die die Idee dahinter war natürlich, dass,
Dann die Massendownloader, die dann da irgendwie diese ganzen Dateien runterladen. Äh bei mega Upload irgendwie acht bis zehn Euro oder ein premium Account daraus für zwanzig Euro buchen. Ähm und dann da alles schön in äh ihre Filmchen runterladen und so.
Ähm und das war ähm,
Ein Verfahren, das äh die Nutzer zumindest sehr gut davor geschützt hat, ähm Abmahnungen zu kassieren, ja? Weil sie ja nur Leute haben und nicht äh nicht geteilt haben.
So das heißt, die haben letztendlich ein ein legalen Hack gemacht, der ähm,
es ihnen ermöglicht hat, relativ gut äh von.
Von dieser ganzen Raubkopiererei zu leben. So und jetzt habe ich mich mal mit einem äh mit einem sehr viel äh,
sehr viel erfahreneren und länger in der Szene äh residierenden Hacker unterhalten und der mir mal so ein bisschen so erzählt hat, äh warum denn überhaupt Kimble in Deutschland so zu Ungnade in Ungnade gefallen ist? Und was er unter anderem gemacht hat, ist
ähm
Boxen, also diese kleinen Kisten, die man, mit denen man das äh Telefonnetz irgendwie in seinem Sinne dazu bringen konnte, Verbindungen herzustellen, für die man nicht bezahlen musste,
Ähm er hatte im Fernsehen gezeigt, woraufhin dann dieses Blueboxing nicht mehr funktionierte. Dann hat er angefangen äh,
Geklaute, also ähm gehackte und kopierte Callingcards zu verkaufen?
Muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären.
Muss man das? Also.
Ja Guthaben, Karten für Telefonie.
Guthaben kann, also wer jetzt eine kostenlose Nummer,
Äh gibt's da eine Credentials ein? Kriegst, ein Freizeichen wählst, die Internationale Nummer und die Verbindung ist dann günstiger, als sie dir jetzt die Telekom oder die Telefonzelle, in der du sitzt, äh bereitgestellt hatte. Und die Karten waren
zeitweise, da waren ja auch tatsächlich richtige Telefonkarten von der Telekom derart manipuliert, dass sie halt immer von, was weiß ich, von zwölf auf null runtergezählt haben und dann wieder von zwölf anfingen. Das heißt, die
die wurden nicht leer, ne? Die wurden halt zu zu ganz erträglichen Preisen verkauft und vermietet.
Da gab's ein sehr, gab's dann sehr rege ähm sehr regen Markt hinter, ne? Das war also alles Prä-Mobilfunk und so weiter
und gerade in Deutschland natürlich viele Menschen, die äh Familie in anderen Ländern haben,
und sich natürlich sehr über solche Angebote freuen. Und da war halt fünfhundert Euro für 'ne Telefonkarte die letztendlich 'n Gegenwert von, was weiß ich, mehreren zehn
äh Mark natürlich, fünftausend Mark, für eine Telefonkarte, den Gegenwert von vielen, vielen zehntausend Mark ähm erzielen kann,
Äh sehr interessant. Wir wurden halt auch vermietet und so weiter. Gab's ein sehr, sehr ähm zwielichtiger äh,
aber auch sehr rege Szene in diesem Bereich. Dann hat er ähm eine äh Mailbox,
Angeboten, also das war ja noch so pre-Internet, Mailbox quasi ein Computer mit mit einer Modembank, wo man sich dann einwählen konnte.
Da gab's dann halt die Baritz.
Und da gab's dann halt die Wahres, also die äh da Raubkopierte, gecrackte Software und,
Er hat quasi diese Box quasi als allererstes mit,
Pate Subscritions angeboten. Also er war der erste, der gesagt hat, ey gibt eine Box, kostet aber
ja? Und hat quasi dann da wieder so vermittelt mit äh mit Raubkopien gehandelt. Die andere bereitgestellt haben, ja? Und als ihm dann irgendwie ähm.
Die die Content-Anbieter oder was an die an den an den äh an den ähm,
an die äh äh an die an die Fittiche wollten damals in Form des äh sehr äh bekannten äh Günther Werner Freiherr von Grafenreuth, ein äh,
Ein Abmahnanwalt, der der frühen Tage ähm,
der ist ihm dann offensichtlich zu dicht auf die Pelle gerückt und dann hat er dem seine Kundenliste verkauft. Und da hat der Grafenreuth halt quasi diese ganzen Kunden, dieser Westmailbox äh.
Echt super. Also erstmal nimmt man die Kohle von den Leuten.
Und dann lieber.
Jetzt besser, das ist schon echt, echt super.
Ja? Super. Äh da war dann war aber auch inzwischen schon Millionär und dann hat er äh sich das.
Das ist so ein.
Da war er schon reich, aber da hat oder hatte er schon das das äh den den Nimbus des Millionärs und hat dann nämlich irgendwie diesen versuchten Anlagebetrug mit Let's Biot dot com gemacht,
wo er irgendwie äh.
Wir retten euch und so.
Genau, der der Laden sollte irgendwie pleite gehen und er hat dann gesagt, äh ich habe ja hier,
Hat sich dann irgendwie ein Hubschrauber gemietet, davor fotografieren lassen, hat gesagt, ich kaufe den ganzen Laden mit Millionen und wenn alles saniert und dann ist die
ist die Aktie hochgegangen und die hat dann alle verkauft, hat den Gewinn eingestrichen. Äh und ähm wurde dann dafür auch in Deutschland verurteil.
Rund um sind unendlich lang und äh er ist im Übrigen auch äh bekannt dafür Leuten, die sozusagen das dokumentieren da auch äh ordentlich äh hinterher zu äh marschieren.
Genau, da müssen wir nur, das haben wir auch mal in einer äh Folge Logbuch Netzpolitik behandelt, nämlich die Drohung, die unser guter Freund Thorsten Kleinst da empfangen hat, der lange nämlich diese.
An der Stelle auch.
Kimble-Report, ja.
Feind, ja. Muss er nochmal raussuchen. Ähm ich wollt's nur so ein bisschen äh verkürzen,
ähm kurzum, also Kimble war im Übrigen auch der erste Mensch und ich glaube mittlerweile gibt's nur einen weiteren, seitdem der äh auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress Hausverbot hat,
Ja, also er wollte da auch mal rein und wurde dann auch äh standesgemäß äh weggeschickt,
seitdem er das nie wieder probiert, weil er dann auch irgendwann Deutschland verlassen muss. So, der ist halt äh dann irgendwie so sozusagen seinen Weg äh durch Asien äh gefunden nach diesem ganzen äh Spektakel. Ähm es hat dann immer weiter geflohen und ich weiß gar nicht, bevor er nach Neuseeland kam,
irgendwie noch in Singapur oder so was und,
Irgendwann hat es ihn dann halt sozusagen wirklich auf die andere Seite des Planetens äh verschlagen, aber auch dort scheint er seine alten Geschäftsmodelle dann wieder zu entdeckt, äh wieder entdeckt zu haben,
wie auch immer. Äh jetzt ist er auf jeden Fall gut dabei und ich glaube, er hat auch in Deutschland nochmal so irgendwas probiert äh mit was war denn das nochmal? Auch hier irgendwie ich zahle Hacker dafür,
dass sie auch so als Friedensengel, was war denn das nochmal?
Irgendwelche die die al-Qaida hacken oder so was.
Ja, ja, genau, diese Terrors. Also, lässt auch wirklich kein Fettnäpfchen aus und,
irgendwie keine Ahnung, schafft er es jetzt da auch wieder durchzukommen. Und dadurch, dass er natürlich jetzt sich so gegen die äh neuseeländische Regierung auch,
stellt quasi indirekt oder zumindest die neuseeländische Regierung auch extrem unter Druck kam, weil sie ja dort, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen den Willen der amerikanischen Behörden ausgeführt haben. Das Ganze auf äh,
äh Jakob, was ja damals zwar bekannt war, aber die Dimension dessen war dem noch nicht so bekannt. Und als jetzt halt mit Snowden äh den Snowden-Dokumenten,
das Ganze auf offensichtlich auch in Neuseeland nochmal eine ganz neue Dimension bekommen hat. Das da haben wir jetzt zu Recht keinen Einblick, aber es scheint dort auf jeden Fall auch äh zu bestimmten,
Ähm äh Instabilitäten im politischen Diskurs gekommen sein.
Ja, da gibt's, da gibt's grade ein politisches Problem. Äh da gibt's gerade richtig äh politisches.
Jetzt ganz äh Opportunist, wie er eben ist, äh stellt er sich halt hin und inszeniert sich natürlich weiterhin so als äh nicht wahr, so als als Widerstandskämpfer der Internetgeneration, ja.
Und hat jetzt die Internetpartei gegründet.
Genau. Weil Piraten war jetzt irgendwie schon durch der Name, jetzt nennt man das irgendwie Internetparty. Und die Internetparty ist halt jetzt für alles, was toll ist.
Ja, er selber kann aber nicht kandidieren, weil er kein Neusee Neuseeländischer Staatsbürger ist. Ähm und hat jetzt diese diese Internetparty gegründet
Neuseeland gerade wirklich in einer Regierungskrise wegen Snowdentüllung, die wir jetzt gerade mal kurz ausklammern. Denn was macht der gute Kimble?
Veranstaltet, macht eine Veranstaltung namens The Moment of Trufe und setzt sich,
Aufs Podium, den,
und rein.
Und die Video-Liveschalte, ja, Julian Assange ja eigentlich schon bekannt für seine Skype äh für seine Skype äh Einblendung, die er immer oben links in seinem.
Aber es scheint die Sanduhr weggelassen zu haben.
Sanduhr ist weg, weil er da irgendwelche Dokumente hinter sich eingeblendet hat. Dafür steht jetzt oben links mega. Denn Julien Assforch und
Waren quasi erste Beta-Tester des von Mega als Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Video ähm Dienstes,
Videotelefoniedienstes äh aufzutreten, ja?
Oh Gott.
Das heißt, du also mir ist völlig mir ist völlig unklar, ähm.
Wie der das geschafft hat, Julian Assange, AdWords Snoaden und Glenworld als Unterstützer für sein Internet Party Wahlkampf in Neuseeland zu bekommen und das offensichtlich keiner der drei,
Einen wohlmeinenden,
Freund in seinem näheren oder erweiterten Umfeld hat, der sagt.
Ja, ich meine äh die haben ja eigentlich kaum Kontakte. Ist ja nicht irgendwie Ehrenmitglied im Computerclub.
Gucken, wie lange noch.
Also das ist das ist wirklich sehr äh das ist äh ähm.
Da ist natürlich jetzt die Dame jetzt echt Sorgen. Oder na ja. Das also.
Sorgen ist jetzt hier vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Oder heißt ja überhaupt noch diverse kim dot com, ne? Hast du jetzt irgendwie.
Heißt.
Typ hat auf jeden Fall schon mehreren Leuten den Deuch in den Rücken gerammt, wenn dafür irgendwie noch eine Mark für ihn über geblieben ist, ne. Und,
Man könnte jetzt wirklich äh bösartig unterstellen, dass er mit dieser Partei äh Gründung jetzt nicht unbedingt äh humanitäre,
Interessen verfolgt, andererseits muss man auch mal für den Typen eine Lanze brechen, der hat jetzt wirklich schon.
Irgendwie diesen Regierung und so ähm schon sehr häufig irgendwie mal,
Übel einen ausgewischt, ja? Und wie der jetzt da irgendwie sich da gegen die äh äh gegen die USA irgendwie in diesem Verfahren in Neuseeland da zur Wehr setzt. Ähm das ist schon
teilweise das ist einer so von denen, wo du denkst, so das Glück ist mit den Doofen. Wie kann der wie was für ein Schwein hat der Typ, ja?
Die Rente, die die die kommen mit Hubschraubern auf sein Gelände, der flüchtet nackt mit der Schrotflinte in seinem Pennegroom und kurz darauf hat er irgendwie Julian Assange. Glen Green und Edward Stone auf dem Podium ist irgendwie der neue Star der Neuseeländischen Politik.
Absurd. Absurd.
Ja, also wir können hoffen, dass da jetzt die Verflechtung nicht so stark werden.
Dass äh ein ein nennenswerter äh Rufschaden für für die drei äh Protagonisten entsteht. Oder äh andererseits kann man natürlich auch hoffen, dass kein ausreichender,
keine ausreichende Rehabilitierung von Kim Schmitz dadurch jetzt entsteht, die er dann wieder irgendwie in ähm in Millionen umsetzt, die er dann irgendwie für Autos ausgibt, ja.
Äh na ja. Vodapools.
Man muss sich wirklich mal irgendwie Dokumentationen mit Kim Schmitz angucken, ne. Er hat ja irgendwie so eine äh ich glaube, seine Frau ist so eine äh Asiatin
irgendwie kam's Gewicht, fünfunddreißig Kilo oder so, aber vor kurzem und er sein Kampfgewicht ist schon in einer anderen Klasse, ne. Ähm der hatte,
gab's auch letztens Gerüchte, dass die jetzt irgendwie ins Gartenhaus gezogen ist, weil die sich jetzt doch nicht mehr vertragen haben oder so
unglaublich, also muss man sich echt mal angucken, wie er dann da auf seinem Anwesen irgendwie rumfährt und so, ja, eine krasse Figur, äh unglaublich. Da kann man da geht einem wirklich die Kinnlade runter.
Trägt auf jeden Fall zur Unterhaltung bei so viel kann man eben schon mal zugestehen.
Unglaublich. Naja, aber äh in der deutschen Hacker-Szene äh ist das wirklich ein Name, der nach wie vor äh.
Nicht so auf Begeisterung stößt.
Nee, eher überhaupt nicht. Also da ähm da äh wird sich so schnell nichts mehr dran ändern.
Klammer auf, was wir jetzt vollständig außen vor gelassen haben, ist dieser ganze äh Regierungsskandalkrise, was nicht alles in Neuseeland. Ähm da müssen sie nochmal nachrecherchieren. Wir warten mal diese Wahlen ab.
Haben wir noch zwei Kurzmeldungen, was ich mal ganz interessant fand. Ähm die das bayerische Landesamt für,
für Datenschutzaufsicht,
hat äh über zweitausend Firmen getestet und zwar deren das SSL oder das TLS auf deren äh Mailservern. Und festgestellt, dass bei einem Drittel ähm,
teilweise überhaupt die Transportverschlüsselung und äh perfekt vorwärtsy nicht aktiviert sind. Und,
das hat siebenhundertzweiundsiebzig Unternehmen in Bayern in dieser Woche Post eingebracht, wo sie das anmahnen,
und sagen, äh fixt mal euren Mailserver. Ähm Klammer auf, wahrscheinlich waren ungefähr mindestens auch siebenhundert,
unter diesen zweitausend Firmen, die ihre Mail einfach bei Google posten und Google natürlich inzwischen da vernünftige vernünftiges TLS mit
und so macht. Aber ich finde das mal einen ganz schönen Ansatz, dass ähm,
hier so ein äh Landesamt für Datenschutzaufsicht wirklich mal hinten was macht, womit sie wirklich auch mal einen Wertbeitrag leisten. Ja, also technische Beratung, ähm technische Hinweise und ähm das ist.
Qualitätssicherung auch so ein bisschen, ne?
Das ist in Ordnung. Das ist natürlich am Ende auch wieder nur ein Tropfen auf einen heißen Stein und so und da ähm aber das ist schon in Ordnung. Letztendlich.
Ist auf jeden Fall besser als dieser dieser Ist-Zustand, wo dann immer die Unternehmen immer alle möglichen äh unglaublichen äh Tolligkeiten behaupten können und ähm ja, das äh ist mal ein schöner Trend in die andere Richtung, ne.
Seal of Aprovil von äh Lok Hochnetzpolitik hier für die.
Wir sind dafür und das muss auch so weitergehen und
übrigens nicht nur Mailserver, da kann man generell auch mal überhaupt äh Webserver machen. Ich denke, wir sind auch nicht mehr so richtig weit davon entfernt, dass sagen wir mal Angebote bestimmter
Güteklasse, also sagen wir mal, da wo schützenswerte Kundendaten vorliegen.
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendeinen Dienst bereitstelle und es gibt da Logins und äh auch da äh müsste man eigentlich auch vorschreiben können, wenn ihr da nicht die,
grundlegende äh SSL-Sicherheit mindestens äh habt, ja, also allein schon mal sicherstellen, dass es das gibt und dass es dann eben auch sagen wir mal eine gewisse Härtung hat, weil wir jetzt auch aus den ganzen Meldungen der letzten Wochen und Monate haben ablesen können
nur ein Schloss oben in der Browserleiste sagt erstmal noch gar nichts aus, sondern es ergibt einfach an vielen Stellen immer wieder die Möglichkeit, einfach Schwachstellen auszunutzen, wenn man
nicht aktuell hält auf der Gegenseite. Ja. Nicht nur beim Browser des.
Stimmt schon, aber wir haben ich bin da im Moment äh von diesem äh von dieser Schiene, das muss auch alles richtig gemacht werden, bisschen äh runter und bin
eher an dem Punkt, dass ich sage, macht es wenigstens überhaupt mal, ja? Dann von mir aus macht's schlechtes
SSL, aber macht wenigstens mal SSL. Macht das von mir aus mit RC4 und dann können wir in der nächsten Charge dann überhaupt mal dahin kommen, äh eure Implementierung auch entsprechend vernünftig zu härten und so, ne? Und das.
Ja gut, aber in dem Moment, wenn man das so ein bisschen auch so hält, wie mit ähm wie soll ich sagen, Umweltgesetzen und den Vorschriften für Katalysatoren bei Autos, wo man dann auch einfach ganz klar sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt hier eine Roadmap und in zwei Jahren
hat jeder Dienst das und das und das zu erfüllen, dann kann man sich heute als Unternehmen schon hinstellen und sagen, wir erfüllen schon die Sicherheitsanforderungen.
Euro vier äh Datenschutz.
Ja, warum nicht? Also ich meine sowas
funktioniert und so auf Gütesiegel stehen eh alle und es schafft auch 'ne gewisse Vergleichbarkeit und ehm das schafft auch, sagen wir mal, eine, eine Grundüber,
keit, was dann eben auch Systeme fördern wird, die das eben dann auch einfach sicherstellen so, ja. Habt ihr denn auch das, was ihr sagt? Und damit wird es auch mehr,
Teil des des Wirtschaftprozesses, weil bisher wissen wir alle, so Sicherheit, na ja, das ist so das, was immer so viel Geld kostet, aber keinen interessiert. Das ändert sich halt jetzt und kann auch zum Sales-Argument werden.
Na ja, also bei Zertifizierung und so bin ich ein bisschen vorsichtig, weil äh das ja bis jetzt, ich meine.
Ja, ich weiß.
Wer Kritiker des BSI in in dieser Zertifizierungsfunktion, aber wir kommen wir wir wissen die Hörerinnen wissen auch was wir meinen. So. Nächstes Thema.
Ja und zwar äh wollen sollen wir jetzt endlich Einblicke erhalten in Googles große Geheimnisse, da warte ich ja schon äh lange dadrauf
und der
Ja, wie soll ich sagen, hier, der Datanya, der uns diese Bresche schlagen will, ist äh niemand geringer, als er bereits erwähnte
Bundesjustizminister Heiko Maas, denn der ist ja der Meinung, dass äh Google doch mal so seinen Suchalgorithmus offenlegen soll. Deshalb ist es ja schon ähm.
Also das ist natürlich eine das ist eine niedliche Idee. Ähm also ist ja jetzt nicht so, als könnte Google sein Suchalgorithmus irgendwie auf Gitter packen, ja. Und ähm.
Jetzt muss man sich natürlich mal überlegen, gehen wir mal davon aus, der Google Suchalgorithmus wäre ein,
Ein homogenes Gebilde, das in irgendeiner Form isolierbar,
dokumentierbar unveröffentlichbar ist, ja? Ähm Klammer auf.
Könnte.
Für Teile des Google Algorithmus,
ist das ohnehin schon der Fall, ne? Also wie man einen Page-Rank errechnet, ist seit äh jeher dokumentiert. Ähm Patch-Rank, das
ursprüngliche, geheim oder die die ursprüngliche Innovation, auf der die Google Suchmaschine zu Beginn,
basiert hat, nämlich die Relevanz einer Seite darin zu bemessen, wie viele andere Seiten dort hin lenken,
Das war der Suchansatz äh von Larry Page entwickelt und eben auch nicht nach der Seite Page, sondern nach äh Larry Page benannt,
Das, weil sie die,
Die ursprüngliche Innovation, äh auf der sich letztendlich dieses dieser gesamte Konzern dann irgendwann mal äh entwickelt hat. Äh davor haben äh die Suchmaschinen oder die.
Die ähm damals gab's auch noch so so ähm wie wie nennt man denn sowas, nicht Archiv, sondern so,
Kataloge dokumentierte Verzeichnisse war das, Verzeichnisdienste, wo dann äh Seiten irgendwie noch von von Menschen auf irgendwie bewertet wurden, so ganz verschiedene
Ansätze, die mehr oder weniger automatisiert werden. Aber das war so ein Teil des Google Algorithmen
oder ein, der zentrale Teil des des Google Ansatzes so. Und dann haben sie natürlich im Laufe der Zeit ähm sehr, sehr viele,
Erweiterung und Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen mussten müssen, denn wenn ich weiß, dass Google eine Seite dadurch bewertet,
wie viele Seiten darauf linken, dann ist natürlich das Sinnvolle, eine Seite, irgendwie tausende von Seiten zu machen, die alle auf meine Linken.
Das heißt, Google hat dann eben ähm Abwehrmechanismen entwickelt, äh eben
zu sagen, okay, nicht nur wer darauf klingt, sondern auch was der Wert wieder der Patrick wiederum dieser Seite ist, ja? Und dann ähm haben sie irgendwann festgestellt, dass Leute anfangen, irgendwie links zu kaufen oder dass
dass die Internetentwicklung dahin geht, dass es Kommentarspalten gibt, in denen Links sind und Menschen dort irgendwie ihren Namen mit einem Link äh unterlegen. Da musste Google halt erkennen, äh was sind hier die Links, ja, äh die die offensichtlich gestreut werden. Das heißt
Google kämpft die ganze Zeit gegen,
Leute, die versuchen, den Google Algorithmus in ihrem Sinne auszutricksen,
Ja und da gibt's dann immer mal wieder so so Phänomene, die auftreten, zum Beispiel, die von mir immer sehr gehasste, äh, Personensuchmaschine Jasmin,
die einige äh Jahre, Google, Suchergebnisse zu Personen dominiert hat, bis Google irgendwann gesagt hat, diese Seite ist wertlos.
Und wir werden die jetzt gezielt diskriminieren. Ja? Oder wir wir bauen in ein ein unseren Algorithmus so, dass derartige Seiten
werden und weg manipuliert werden. Ähm guter Kumpel von mir hat mal äh Search Engagin, Optomizession für seine eigene Seite gemacht und hat dann irgendwie ein riesiges Buch darüber gelesen
wie Sätze zu formulieren sind, damit Google die versteht. Das heißt, da wurden quasi.
Oder es wird auch heute noch gemacht. Da werden dann Seiten,
so formuliert in einer Grammatik und einer spezifischen Wiederholung des Suchbegriffes, dass der Google Algorithmus.
Also quasi das die die der Satzbau auf dieser Seite,
Dem aktuellen Level des Suchalgorithmusses von Google entspricht,
damit Kugel gut versteht, was auf dieser Seite ist, ja?
Man schreibt überhaupt gar nicht mehr für die Leser, sondern man schreibt eigentlich nur noch für seine Suchmaschine und benutzt dabei so eine etwas immer so den aktuellen Stand der KI äh und wie so das Baby langsam größer wird, umso äh mehr.
Anpassen, weil Google dann irgendwann.
Nähert, nähert sich dann alles an so.
Das heißt, Fragmente.
Boris Becker ist ein Tennisspieler. Er hat gut gespielt.
Lerne hier mehr über Boris Becker, äh ja, Boris Becker, äh Tennis ist ein Spaltsport, so ne, also.
Ne? Und das aber das ist ein, das ist ein ein ständig in Entwicklung äh stehen.
Permanenter Kampf vor.
Genau. Und weil sich immer wieder dann quasi Fragmente ergeben, wo eben man lernt, wie man seine Seite so optimiert, dass dass man quasi Google austrägst so.
Das mal so zu Suchmaschinen. Gleichzeitig hat der gute Herr Maas aber natürlich Recht, dass er sagt, wenn dein,
Deine Seite oder dein Business Case. Zu dem zentralen Suchbegriff nicht unter den Top ten oder top drei Google-Ergebnissen ist,
Dann hast du kein Businessmodell. Dann hast du ein Insolvenzverfahren,
Ja und ähm,
Das ist natürlich ein Problem, weshalb er jetzt sagt, also in in technischer Unkenntnis sagt, das muss offengelegt werden. Das geht aber natürlich nicht, denn also erstens ist dieser äh Algorithmus,
enorm komplex und funktioniert ja auch auf jedes Suchwort, ja. Also es ist ja nicht so irgendwie als hättest du irgendwie Function,
Google Doppelpunkt. Ähm und dann kommt irgendwie ein Suchbegriff rein und dann sagt er dir an erster Stelle steht so und so, an zweiter Stelle so und so, ja? Und würde jetzt zwei folgende Maßnahmen ergreifen, könnte es eins überholen.
Da kommt nichts.
Vor allem ist es ja auch hochgradig von den Daten abhängig, die sich ja auch am laufenden Meter ändern. Also es ist überhaupt nicht greifbar. Am besten will nicht.
Nicht deswegen nennt man es ja auch Algorithmus äh Algorithmus ist ja der Begriff für etwas was so was Programm so komplex programmiert ist, dass es der Programmierer selbst auch nicht mehr versteht. Deswegen nennt das dann Algorithmus.
Vorher ist es eine eine Funktion oder eine Methode.
Programm. Ja.
Okay, also ähm so das heißt, ähm,
In dem Moment, wo du den Algorithmus offen legen würdest, könnten,
und alle legitimen Anbieter ihre Inhalte passgenau darauf zuschneiden. Das heißt, in dem Moment ist der gesamte Algorithmus kaputt.
Ja? Das heißt, der Algorithmus funktioniert nur deshalb, weil seine genaue Gewichtung unbekannt ist. Und Google sagt dann zum Beispiel so was, was ich zum Beispiel eine sehr äh tolle Ankündigung fand, dass sie gesagt haben, Freunde,
in Zukunft wird es zum.
Zu der Bewertung einer Seite beitragen, dass diese vernünftiges HTTPS anbietet.
Dann erstmal was, was sie sagen,
Inwiefern das jetzt dein äh deinen Rang verbessert oder verschlechtert, wenn du es tust oder nicht tust, darüber macht Google keine Auskunft und es wäre auch eben, wie gesagt, fatal, wenn man das reversen könnte. Das heißt, Google lässt die Leute im im
dunkeln da darüber und ändert natürlich auch andauernd die Gewichtung an den einzelnen Dingen, auf die sie achten.
Und das müssen sie so machen, denn sonst wäre äh äh Google im Arsch und dann wäre das Internet kaputt.
Wäre aber auf jeden Fall das eins A Security Sicherheitssiegel, wenn man sozusagen davon ausgehen kann, dass wenn man sein SSL auf den absolut neuesten Stand bringt, also alle Algorithmen unterstützt et cetera, alle Versionen.
Nee, der Trick ist ja nicht euer Algorithmus zu unterstützen.
Also nein Entschuldigung, nicht alle, sondern die
also das Beste sozusagen. Also es empfohlene äh Paket äh anzubieten und den alten Kram auch hinten rüber äh fallen zu lassen und damit
nochmal so ein paar SEO-Punkte äh äh abzugreifen. Da dürsten sie natürlich alle danach und ich glaube, wenn das irgendwie uchbar wird, dann bewegt sich auf einmal eine ganze Menge, ne?
Passieren, dass da da nutzt Google eben sein.
Genau.
Seinen Einfluss. Ähm denn das kann.
Also jetzt ein positiver Hinsicht natürlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Tante Tante hat auch HTPS, ich weiß nicht, ob's ordentlich ist, habe ich mir nicht angeguckt. Tante Jürgen Reuter, ähm,
hier auch schon mal erwähnt ähm prominentes Mitglied der Sparkaria, der hat da zwei ähm gute Artikel zugeschrieben, einmal sogar als Gastautor für Spiegel
online und dann auch nochmal auf seinem eigenen Blog wo er,
eben nochmal genau erklärt, was wir auch gerade versucht haben, warum eine Suchmaschine ihren Algorithmus nicht offenlegen kann und gleichzeitig aber auch Transparenzkriterien für äh Suchmaschinen,
da formuliert. Die.
Davon, warum hast du mir das jetzt vorgeschlagen?
Naja, also das, dass man also welche, über welche Teile einer Suchmaschine könnten sie transparent sein? Ja, aber das sind irgendwie so fünf, sechs Forderungen, die würde ich dann der geneigten Leserin empfehlen.
Ja
Ähm aber also diese Forderung klingt natürlich spannend, äh ist aber eben leider eben äh wirklich, wirklich höchst äh unrealistisch.
Lieber Herr mach's.
Ciao. Damit bleibt uns nur noch äh das Ende der Sendung einzuleiten.
Genau, das Ende der Sendung ist.
Ein größeres Buch aufgeschlagen in dem.
Ich Größeres, größeren Stapel äh äh wie heißt das, Lieferscheine heißt das, ne, was was in einem Paket mit drin liegt. Also,
Ähm ich war ja letzte Woche nicht da und als ich zurückkam, hatte ich ein bisschen Ärger bei der Arbeit, weil da so viele Pakete für mich waren. Ähm,
Und zwar äh,
Gab es eine eine wahre Flut an an äh Spenden, Produktspenden und ähm,
Was mir dabei jetzt ein bisschen unangenehm ist, dass bei denen, die von Amazon versandt wurden, stehen dann auch die Namen.
Da steht aber jetzt auch immer der gleiche Name.
Und das ist der von Bernd. Also Bernd, herzlichen Dank für für die anhaltende Großzügigkeit. Mehr kann ich da nicht zu sagen.
Also wirklich sehr herzlichen Dank. Die die Whisky-Sammlung hat sich da auch nochmal vergrößert und äh wurde dann gestern auch eine eingehenden äh Verköstigung unterzogen.
Nur der öffentlichen, Teil öffentlichen.
Mein Nachbar äh der hat ja auch immer versucht eine Whisky-Sammlung aufzubauen, aber diese diese Getränke sind ja relativ teuer. Und er hat dann immer nur so ein, zwei Flaschen bestellt und
hat sich dann halt zur Angewohnheit gemacht, jeden Abend wenn er dann von einem anstrengenden Arbeitstag nach Hause kam, dann doch auch nochmal so einen kleinen Whiskey äh zu verköstigen,
natürlich dann dazu geführt hat, dass diese Whisky-Sammlung nie entstanden ist, weil er die viel zu schnell ausgetrunken hat
in so deswegen war ich jetzt ganz stolz ihn mal zu einer Whiskyverköstigung einladen zu können,
und dann sind halt noch einige andere Dinge gekommen wo jetzt immer steht Lieferschein bestellt von Linus Neumann,
Das heißt, ich fürchte, dass sich hier Namen hinter äh verbergen, denen äh Dank gebührt. Und den ich jetzt leider nicht äh,
Personen zu Teil kommen lassen kann. Deswegen würde ich euch doch bitten, mal äh.
Wobei ja Bernd durchaus auch als Meter sind taktische Variabler an der Stelle äh.
Da ist noch ein Nachname bei und der Nachname ist nicht liefert oder lauert.
Deswegen glaube ich, dass es sich um eine natürliche Person handelt.
Verstehe.
Aber also ähm es wäre nett, wenn wenn ihr da nochmal die Gelegenheit ergreifen würdet, ähm mir
vielleicht eine kurze Mail zukommen zu lassen äh unter äh Linus Neumann DE Slash Kontakt gibt's da eine Möglichkeit zu ähm damit da jetzt niemand äh ungedankt,
seine Großzügigkeit hat walten lassen.
Ja, das war schön. Soll ich mich dem noch irgendwie anschließen?
Du kannst gerne.
Ja schon mal gesagt, aber ähm bin ja gerade ganz großer äh Freund von dieser tollen äh Integration von Instacast, wer von.
Ach so, ich dachte, du wolltest auch was jetzt mir schenken. Ach so, du wolltest jetzt von, ach so, ja okay, kannst du auch machen, ist in Ordnung? Ja, ne, kannst du mal.
Denn hin? Wunschlisten größeres hier. Nee, nee,
Nein, aber die äh die angehende äh Befletterung ähm des Programms, die zeigt auf jeden Fall Wirkung
und ähm von daher äh jedem auch einen Dank, der äh das macht und wer das noch nicht gemacht hat, sollte mal vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken. Das hilft.
Wir haben auch,
Nach wie vor vier Rückmeldungen zu den Sendungen in den Kommentaren, das finde ich gut. Wenn da eine lebendige äh Debatte äh entsteht, vor allem wenn sie sich äh in so höflichen Bahnen äh bewegt,
in allermeisten Fällen der Fall ist. Und ja, das war's dann dann eigentlich erstmal wieder für diese,
Die nächsten Wochen bleiben ruppig in der Terminplanung. Wir können noch nicht viel äh dazu sagen. Wir.
Sind jetzt die Boxhandschuhe anlegen und schauen, ob wir da noch irgendwie Möglichkeiten finden.
Genau, schwierig. Jetzt kommt die Kälte.
Gibt's denn sonst noch irgendwas, was anzukündigen ist? Ich äh ich habe jetzt wirklich echt,
Sorge, dass ich da irgendwelche.
Wichtigen Veranstaltung.
Namen oder Veranstaltungen oder so unerwähnt lasse. Da hätte ich jetzt Angst.
Ja. Äh,
an der Stelle vielleicht nochmal der Hinweis an Leute, die im Netz politischen Umfeld ihrer Auffassung nach interessante Veranstaltungen veranstalten oder auch an ihn teilnehmen und von denen ihr meint,
dass sie uns interessieren könnten, nicht jetzt unbedingt nur was unsere persönliche Teilnahme betrifft, sondern.
Nur Buch äh Buch Rezensionsexemplare und so ist natürlich auch, also könnt ihr auch machen.
Ja, na gut, darum ging's mir jetzt nicht, sondern häufig finden so Veranstaltungen statt und dann hat man sie irgendwie auf einmal nicht mehr aufm Zeiger gehabt. Damit,
einhergehend aber auch gleich der Hinweis, wie ihr euch wahrscheinlich denken könnt
nur weil wir das dann per Mail mitbekommen haben, heißt das nicht automatisch, dass wir das dann auch in irgendeiner Form in der Sendung verbraten, das kann zwei Gründe sein, haben. Entweder wir finden da Veranstaltungen doof, das würden wir aber nicht zugeben, sondern wir würden's dann einfach nur verschweigen und die Ausrede ist natürlich
äh haben wir verpeilt. Ne.
Nein, also,
bei Veranstaltung ist immer so eine Sache, wir hatten das bei Netzpolitik, org lange äh sogar mal war ich immer der Verfechter davon, da so einen Kalender auch mal,
ähm,
bereitzustellen. Ähm das Problem damit ist immer, dass du natürlich nicht so dann von jeder Piratenpartei Splittergruppe äh den
Frühschoppen, Stammtisch, ankündigen möchtest, ne?
Sondern das ist, dass man irgendwie quasi einzelne ähm relevante Veranstaltungen äh dann die auch, sage ich mal, vielleicht,
bundesweit interessant sind, da äh ankündigen möchte. Also nehmt uns das bitte nicht übel, wenn wenn wir euer, eure,
Zwanzigste Krypto-Party, die wir sehr würdigen und wo wir es toll finden, dass ihr die macht, dann jetzt nicht mit aufnehmen in die äh.
Genau, aber manchmal gibt's ja einfach auch wirklich so Veranstaltungen, die man ähm gerne.
Bekommen hätte, aber einfach nicht mitbekommen hat. So jetzt haben wir genug über einen heißen Brei äh herumgeredet und uns um Kopf und Kragen äh gebracht. Und dann bleibt uns nur noch zu sagen, tschüss. Tschüss. Na?
Tschüss. Ja, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.